hey guys welcome to rpi developer full
course in this full course we will cover
the core topics of rpa and its popular
tools like ui path and automation
anywhere
rpa is in demand and highly growing
field
rpa is the use of software with
artificial intelligence and machine
learning capabilities to handle high
volume repeated tasks that were
previously required humans to perform
ui path and automation anywhere are the
most popular rpa tools available in the
market
so if you are interested in rpa and its
tools like uipath and automation
anywhere then you are in the right place
this video will help you understand the
concepts of rpa
so here is the list of topics covered
we'll first start with what is rpa
top 10 reasons to learn rpa
rpa developer salary and resuming
rpa examples then we will go to most
popular rpa tool ui path
and we will see what is ui path
ui path installation
ui part tutorial
ui path orchestrator
uipath robotic enterprise framework
uipath web automation
uipath excel automation
and uipath interview questions
then we will go to another rpa tool
automation anywhere and look at
automation anywhere installation
anywhere tutorial
automation anywhere excel operations
automation anywhere interview questions
rpa using python
and then we will see some of the rpa
real-time projects
and finally we will look at our ba
interview questions i am sure you are
excited to get started with the full
course
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
click down the bell icon so you never
miss an update from simply learn
so without wasting any further time
let's get started with rpa developer
full course
this is jim he is an accountant in a
multinational company he handles several
invoices and other financial records
like monetary transactions liabilities
checks and ledgers on a daily basis one
of his tasks is to copy all the relevant
information from these invoices such as
the name of the company invoice id and
data processing into a spreadsheet and
mail the sheet along with other
financial reports to his superiors by
the end of the day as any prompt
employee he transfers all the
information to the sheet attaches the
reports and sends them over to his boss
via email every day
but over a period he starts finding this
task to be time consuming and repetitive
frustrated jim looks for a way to reduce
the time and effort it takes to complete
the task and voila
he stumbles across robotic process
automation aka rpa using robotic process
automation he builds a simple bot that
extracts information from several
invoices into an excel sheet attaches
all the necessary financial reports and
sends them over to his superiors via
email at a specific time every day
so what exactly is robotic process
automation
robotic process automation rpa is the
use of software with artificial
intelligence and machine learning
capabilities to handle high volume
repetitive tasks that previously
required humans to perform some of these
tasks include addressing queries making
calculations maintenance of records and
performing transactions
there are several misconceptions about
rpa rpa is not a humanoid robot it does
not have a physical form and no
resemblance to humans rpa cannot replace
humans or replicate human cognitive
functions it does not have a brain of
its own
and cannot perform logical or critical
thinking as humans do the working of rpa
includes four crucial phases
one the planning phase typically
involves gathering the processes to be
automated identifying the test objects
and finalizing the implementation
approach
two the development phase includes the
creation of automation workflows as per
the agreed plan
three deployment and testing is a vital
phase
since it uncovers any unexpected outages
and ensures a bug-free product
four
lastly there's the support and
maintenance phase which ensures that the
product is continuously updated with
smooth deployment across the user base
to meet the objectives of rpa tools are
used
these rpa tools are software
applications that can configure tasks
and automate them
some of the popular rpa tools in the
market are uipath automation anywhere
blue prism workfusion pega and redwood
among others
when it comes to quality rpa ensures
consistent error-free output
leading to reduced operational risks
this in turn improves customer
satisfaction
in the area of delivery rpa can help
decrease the average handling time and
this enhances the customer experience
and ensures 24 7 business continuity
with respect to cost according to nascom
domestic businesses can reduce the cost
by up to 65 through rpa
it offers a higher roi by driving
positive returns within quarters as
opposed to years
other advantages of rpa include reduced
training costs minimal utilization of
i.t resources and easier software
migration
today many domains and industries like
banking and finance i.t integration
processes human resources insurance
agencies marketing and sales and
customer relationship management readily
deploy rpa
rpa service adoption has been showing
tremendous growth since 2016 and will
continue to increase beyond 2020
according to mckenzie's research
knowledge and work automation could have
an economic impact of five to seven
trillion dollars by the year 2025
it will impact more than 230 million
knowledge workers which constitute nine
percent of the global workforce
any company which is labor intensive
where people are performing high volume
high transaction functions stand to
benefit the most with rpa adoption
boosting their capabilities and saving
money and time
now that we've discussed what rpa is and
isn't here's a question for you
which of the following is not an rpa use
case
1. email query processing
2. data extraction
three image recognition
four payroll processing
give it a thought and leave your answers
in the comments section below three
lucky winners will receive amazon gift
vouchers
rpa offers the ability to automate
business processes quickly and easily it
pays the way for digital transformation
by placing automation tools at the
user's disposal so what are you waiting
for
get certified and become an rpa
developer to build a bright future in
the field of automation
10 reasons why you should learn rpa
but before jumping into it let me give
you a brief insight into what exactly
rpa is
now do you remember the time you used
the digital calculator in maybe your
calculus class
it made it so much easier for you to
arrive at an answer
calculators undoubtedly helped you solve
complex mathematical problems which
previously required a lot of time
and of course
doing manual calculations have
inherently
several errors
but does calculation account for
automation
well no
a conventional calculator requires
manual input
so this is partial automation
automating the usage of a calculator
that requires zero human intervention is
what rpa does
so what exactly is rpa
robotic process automation is the use of
software with artificial intelligence
and machine learning capabilities to
handle high volume repeated tasks that
previously required humans
now some of these tasks include
addressing queries
making calculations maintaining records
or even making transactions
so why is rpa gaining popularity so
rapidly and why do companies and techies
have rpa perspectives
so here are the 10 reasons why one
should learn rpa
so number 10 fast implementation
now getting data entry bots up and
running
goes quickly
implementing a new rpa software system
certainly happens much faster than
training a new person
you can have these data entry bots up
and running in just days
in contrast if you wanted to hire a new
human employee you'd be taking a lot of
time in sorting out resumes conducting
interviews going through the entire
boring hiring process and then finally
when you find the right person you'd
have to spend time and energy on
training them
however in case of rpa all of this is
countered
number nine we have no training time
so now this is an important one
if your process changes and the bots
need to learn something new you can
either replace them with new bots or
alter their programming
now that again goes much faster than
training employees for new tasks
in terms of costs training an employee
for a new task will pan out to be way
more expensive and time consuming
next up the bots will never quit
now with rpa you don't have to worry
about employees quitting or dealing with
the turnover
bots don't care how hard they're working
or how boring their job is or how
repeatedly they're doing the same tasks
again yes it would be ironic if the bots
got tired
software bots can work all the time 24
hours a day every single day of the year
at 100 capacity
now rpa doesn't take holidays it doesn't
have sick needs and of course they do
not have unproductive days at all
well isn't that a treat to have someone
who never retires or decides it's time
to move to a different job
next up minimal i.t resources
maintaining software bots requires
minimal id resources
in some cases
it doesn't id doesn't need to get
involved at all
your rpa systems will be managed by the
software provider
they're responsible for maintenance and
updates all of that
it completely takes the burden off it
and saves your company a whole lot of
money
roi is visible
now every organization wants to quantify
their gains
many of these organizations do not know
how they should determine their roi
but when it comes to adopting robotic
process automation roi is visible it
defines a clearer path to demonstrate
its returns
complex problems can be solved
now as our data sources and analytical
capabilities have grown
so has the time required to build
various reports
robotic process automation system is
ideal for solution
to solve these types of problems
the system stores the information and it
can also remember and transform this
information very easily
that means this makes you auditable and
tax ready
software migration
now it's a fact that software migrations
are time consuming and costly
migrating to a new software could take
months and cost could turn out to be
tens or thousands of millions of dollars
what's even more frustrating is that at
all times
certain features and functionalities
which may have functioned in a
particular way in a previous version may
not even be present in the updated
version
so rpa helps with data migration with
accuracy speed and continuous updating
of software
rpa has a free tier
many rpa vendors offer free tiers
some of these vendors are blue prism
automation anywhere ui path among others
these rpa software vendors are offering
high
rpa software notably ui path with their
community edition and workfusion with
their rpa express
this helps lower the total cost of
ownership
there's no rip and replace
now rpa doesn't jeopardize an employee's
job but helps with the growth of new
jobs
to do your work you'll need some
additional software yes and virtual
machines to deploy fully independent
digital bots
but you may not need to rip and replace
your existing infrastructures
also there's a common misconception that
rpa could steal our jobs
well that's not true
monitoring and controlling these bots
are completely the responsibilities of
the developer
as a result rpa does not pull down your
existing systems but it leverages them
lastly popularity and high salary
according to glassdoor the average
salary of an rpa developer in the u.s is
77 000 us dollars and in india the
beginning salary for an rpa developer is
around 4.65 lakhs per annum
top tier companies like dell ibm
accenture capgemini cognizant among
others are readily hiring rpa developers
now with that let's move on to the
growth projections of rpa
now looking at the graph here
both rps software and services
increased by huge amounts during between
2016 and 2020.
according to mckinsey research knowledge
and work automation could have an
economic impact of five to seven
trillion dollars by the year 2025.
it will touch more than 230 million
knowledge workers which are which
constitute about nine percent of the
global workforce
any company which is labor intensive
where people are performing high volume
high transaction functions will boost
their capabilities and save money
and time with rpa
now this is all you need to know about
why one should learn rpa
but if you're looking to become a
developer let's look at some of the job
roles and responsibilities
rpa developers are responsible for the
creation
design development and implementation of
rpa systems
an rpa developer is expected
to provide guidance with process design
design develop test automation flip
workflows
deploy rpa competence be it bots robots
or development tools
support the implementation of rpa
solutions
create process documentation
and also assure the quality of the
automation
moving on
so you must be wondering how simply
learn can help you
now if you're looking to make a career
as an rpa developer then i'd recommend
you go through some of the course
courses offered by us
so you could visit our official website
say simplylearn.com
and say rpa
you get a few options and depending on
your requirement you can take up the
appropriate course
so we have rpa training using uipath
all right so you can click on that and
get a brief overview of it
so
this certification training is designed
to help you master rpa processes and
best practices now this mainly focuses
on uipath certification
it also gives you an insight into the
key features
you can opt for your required training
options
and then you have a course curriculum
and then you have eligibility so this
training is ideal for anyone with a
technical background and anybody who
wants to kick start a career in this
field so professionals can also benefit
from this training
and
be developers project managers
architects or product managers
next up we have introduction to robotic
process automation
now then again you can look at the key
features what it provides you have
different courses for individuals and
businesses
you can go through the description
and if you think this suits your
requirements and you can opt this
and again it gives you the course
overview
if this is what you want to learn then i
think this course is for you
and lastly
we have automation anywhere certified
advanced rpa training course
now this is for automation anywhere
certification so anybody looking for
that should totally go for this
we again have
the overview here the key salient
features
we have training options
and then the criteria and course content
so you could go
go ahead and look at this and then
choose the appropriate one so let's
begin by understanding who is an rpa
developer
now generally speaking an rpa developer
is someone who works cross-functionally
with business operations and business
analysts to create an optimize workflow
processes
however this is a relatively new career
path and many organizations formal
titles for rpa developers differ
now other similar positions may include
titles like process designer or
automation architect but no matter the
title the role of a successful rpa
developer
involves to design develop and implement
rpa systems
in order to automate a business process
an rpa developer will be required to
create workflow diagrams and
strategically document the
implementation he is also responsible
for bug fixes so coding skills are
important now in order to be a
successful rpa developer you must have
the ability to navigate various
appropriate technologies such as ui path
or automation anywhere
next up is rpa growth projections
now looking at the curve both rpa
software and services increased by huge
amounts between 2016 and 2020 and beyond
according to next research knowledge and
work automation could have an economic
impact of about five to seven trillion
us dollars for the year 2025. it will
touch more than 230 million knowledge
workers which constitute up to nine
percent of the global workforce now any
company which is labor intensive where
people are performing high volume high
transaction functions will boost their
capabilities and save money and time
with rpa
now that we've established that rpa has
a steep growth curve let's look at the
rpa job roles that you should look out
for
we have the rpa developer
senior rpa developer
rpa process architect
rp developer senior consultant
project manager
lead developer
business analyst and rpa data analyst
now these job roles come with specific
responsibilities depending on the
designation
however there are a few common
responsibilities of an rpa developer
let's go ahead and check them out
now the first one is strategic planning
skills
now planning is a crucial phase in any
development life cycle the rpa developer
regardless of the designation should
possess the aptitude to ensure strategic
planning
planning includes the design development
and implementation of rpa systems
this also helps streamline the business
next up is strong analytical skills now
to understand the client's requirements
and cater to the needs accordingly is
crucial
analytical skills are also important to
predict or identify potential bugs and
errors and rectify them
now this scale is especially required if
you are involved in the overall
development
next we have strong problem solving
skills now this again is extremely
crucial to predict any outages and equip
the entire unit to overcome any
unforcing interruptions from the
business perspective as well problem
solving skills play a significant role
in ensuring smooth conduction of tasks
experience in any programming language
such as c c plus plus python ruby java
or dot net is also important
hands-on experience in rpa tools and
cognitive platforms such as blue prism
automation anywhere ui path open span
etc is necessary
communication skills are pivotal for any
organization the developer should be
outspoken and articulate any new ideas
he should also be confident to raise
concerns and be as transparent as
possible in the long run this only
proves to be helpful to the organization
lastly we have exposure to sql now
experience with database be it sql or
nosql is highly preferred it's always an
added advantage if you have the
knowledge about accessing and managing
databases
next up we have rpa developer salaries
now the salaries will differ depending
on the location your experience and also
the designation
now in the u.s here are the job salaries
and the roles
according to glassdoor an rpa developer
in the us earns around 76 000 us dollars
per year
the nrp developer senior consultant
earns around 99 000 us dollars per year
an rpa process architect earns an
average salary of 95 000 us dollars and
a senior rpa developer earns an average
salary of 92 000 us dollars
an rpa project manager earns around 73
000 us dollars per annum an rpa lead
developer earns an average salary of 99
000 us dollars per annum an rpa business
analyst earns around 68 000 us dollars
per annum and the data analyst earns
around 62 000 us dollars per annum
moving on to india the average salary of
an rpa developer is around 5 lakhs 98
000 rupees
that of a senior consultant a senior rp
developer and an rpa lead developer is
around 14 lakhs per annum
and the average salary of an rpa
business analyst is around 5 lakhs 40
000 rupees
now let me quickly run you through a
sample resume of an rpa developer now
this is just a template and you can
alter it according to your needs first
up is your general information like name
phone number and your email id
then you can give a quick description
about yourself and your strengths you
can also mention the objective as to why
you're applying and what you're looking
for in the organization
you can include your linkedin profile
link and your github link one look at
your linkedin profile is enough for
anybody to gather all the information
necessary so make sure that it's updated
moving on you could mention your
experience now here you would have to
mention the names of your previous
organizations along with your
designation and the tenure
you could also include your key
responsibilities in these organizations
along with the responsibilities you
could also mention the awards that you
received in your organizations
next up is your educational background
you can mention the university that you
graduated from and this require that you
have a degree in computer science you
can also go ahead and mention your gpa
the next section is skills now this is
pretty crucial in the technical skills
section you could mention about
different rpa tools that you've worked
on if you're good at a particular
programming language go ahead and
mention that as well
as mentioned earlier any experience in
database management is an added
advantage
if you have any experience go ahead and
mention that moving on to non-technical
skills you could mention any
extracurricular activities that you're
proud of some soft skills that you feel
worth mentioning can be added in this
section mentioning the languages that
you know can also boost your resume
now given all this it's fundamental that
you do not lie on your resume in this
video we will be looking at the robotic
process automation example let us
consider a discussion between john and
jaime john is very curious and wants to
know how and where rpa is used in
different fields
jaime being a developer helps john in
understanding the rpa examples even if
you are curious to know the applications
of rpa then you are at the right place
so let's get started
the first example is customer service
let's look at the problem statement
a customer representative must
understand and solve the customer
queries carry out the necessary actions
by switching between the various
softwares and applications and inform
the customer
this must wait while the representative
is busy dealing with data sometimes
asking for information that has already
been requested this tends to decrease
customer satisfaction and extends call
duration
the solution requires identifying
frequently asked customer questions
assessing customer representative
actions in response to those questions
and developing rpa solutions to
facilitate those questions
when several sets of information need to
be coordinated across systems the
customer service representative can
launch a bot the bot completes all
actions in seconds with the press of a
button
for frequently asked questions a
dashboard can be created a customer
service representative will fill out the
necessary information to receive the
queries and bots will use that data in
multiple systems to complete the
transaction let's look at an example
consider a scenario where a company was
providing support to the client and the
company was supposed to handle a large
number of calls approximately 20 000
calls per month which required a
significant amount of time spent in the
support team because of the system's
complexity an executive's average time
was about 10 minutes the system was
inefficient and slow resulting in the
poor customer service
with the rpa solution the organization
gained a virtual team that can complete
the task in less than a minute resulting
in a drastic reduction in an execution
time
the rpa board performs the following
task
loading a comprehensive customer profile
obtaining a detailed billing information
user preferences and other user
information are being updated
resolving common but simple customer
issues
let's look at the second example
financial service
financial service involves compiling and
combining financial information from
various departments and storing the
records in a system
data is manually extracted from a bank
statements to reconcile documents and
link them to its forms using detailed
spreadsheets
to complete the reports business rely on
excel legacy software and manual labor
which is tedious and time consuming
solution
robots can generate invoices in seconds
prompting clients to pay more quickly
rpa in financial services tracks and
standardizes and validates payments
process orders and avoids errors and is
always on top of things such a
disciplined assistant makes the
customers experience less stressful
adding value to the service provider
rpa in finance eliminates the need for
endless email correspondence and ensures
a smooth payment approval process
matches invoices to responsible parties
and sets deadline reminders
automated data entry speeds up the
process and relieves human employees of
huge tasks this enables precise and
structured invoice processing
consider a financial service company
that's having difficulty extracting data
from financial documents efficiently and
accurately in order to generate ratings
using rpa company implemented an
application that recognized and
processed data
this enabled the client to quickly and
cost effectively automate
the tasks performed by rpa bots in
financial service are
investment management
reconciliation of bank statements
organizing the finances
record of accounts receivables and pay
the third example is hr service
this operation includes numerous routine
steps such as interview scheduling
record keeping resume screening
candidate shortlisting induction
training and onboarding pairing and
firing place a significant burden on hr
and other support functions such as i.t
security and facilities management
particularly for medium and large
businesses while it is expensive to
build a solution that encompasses all of
these functions and completes the
necessary task for new or departing
employees some employees can be sloppy
with recording absences vacation or in
general using the existing absence
management system
so the possible solution for this is rpa
can be used to collect and screen
resumes and online application forms
contact through background checks and
compare the information to all the
relevant job requisitions this allows
the best candidates to be shortlisted
rpa can be used quickly to create offer
letters for new employees
that are both personalized and accurate
can also validate records by
cross-checking data such as absentees
reports against time logged in the
corporate network and alerting when
information is missing or inconsistent
talent acquisition team of a company
automated aspects of onboarding process
for new employees
previously the onboarding paperwork was
completed manually by one person
consuming a significant amount of
employees time that could have been
spent on more valuable work
this type of work that no one wants to
do day after day
the company understands that an hr
department wants to provide a digital
and straightforward experience the task
required a lot of copy and paste
activities with the implementation of
rpa the bot completed the onboarding
paperwork in less time allowing hrs to
spend more time on corporate social
responsibilities hiring talent
initiatives and improving a company's
reputation
the tasks performed by rpa bots in hr
service are screening resumes onboarding
of new hires
attendance management
induction and training
employment management and survey report
the fourth example is telecom service
the telecommunications industry involves
high frequency of manual repetitive
rules-based processes all of which are
critical for providing appropriate
service delivery thus the foundation of
telecommunications is made up of process
that are highly amenable to automation
for telecommunication companies looking
to improve their customer service high
reliability and accuracy of process
outcomes are required
solution the use of robotic process
automation in telecom reduces error
rates to close to zero
improves data quality improves customer
service and increases operational
efficiency all while contributing
significantly to cost reduction
rpa technology can capture the business
process task performed by a telecom
company's employees
based on the employee section a
well-structured workflow can be
generated which serves as the foundation
for automated process by mapping each
process step with its significant cost
for manual execution it is simple to
determine which action should be
automated to maximize return on the
investment
consider an example a telecommunications
and media company decided to automate
its order creation and service removal
process to cut costs associated with the
company speed booster discount service
and deal with a massive amount of
transactional data
with the implementation of rpa it
becomes simple to automate the order
build process and service removal
activity
the tasks performed by rpa boards in
telecom service are
it checks on the credit and sim card
swapping the solution of customer
complaints
porting customer phone numbers
responding to questions from partners
the fifth example is healthcare service
healthcare systems contain numerous
burdensome tasks that involve
significant resource allocation such as
claim management this results in high
operational cost and slow process
every industry has inefficiencies but
few face the healthcare industry's
challenges strict regulations regarding
patient data and lack of resources to
deal with such rules building takes time
after a healthcare service is provided
due to manual and repetitive task in the
management process
management process include document and
data input processing and evaluation in
addition to the automating time
consuming task patients can schedule
appointments without the intervention of
hospital employees credit to rpa
technology along with eliminating the
need of resource allocation for
scheduling by allowing patients to
reschedule appointments more quickly
this application can improve customer
relations rpa allows healthcare
providers to track and document each
process step in structured log files to
comply with external audits
rpa improves data confidentiality
because bots handle this process
let's consider an example
daily a healthcare organization deals
with the process of patient transaction
data
customer detailed recording claims to
the process and data reconciliation for
health care schemes are some of the
manual process they must streamline
daily the primary goal was to increase
the efficiency of existing approaches to
achieve greater accuracy with reduced
turnaround time
robotic process automation was
implemented and the most significant
possible impact was obtained rpa
platform handled claims processing and
health data reconciliation program
healthcare was able to reduce turnaround
time with this solution
the tasks performed by rpa boards in
healthcare service are
appointment scheduling regulatory
compliance data entry
and supporting analytics to improve
treatment what is ui path
uipath is a robotic process automation
tool for large scale end-to-end
automation
for an accelerated business change it
provides solution for business to
automate routine office activities
it uses a variety of methods to
transform tedious tasks into automated
process
daniel dines and marius tirka romanian
entrepreneurs founded uipath in
bucharest in 2005.
the first uipath desktop automation
product line was launched in 2013 giving
business rpa tools to automate manual
and repetitive office task
let's look at the features of uipath
drag and drop workflow the user of
uipath will develop visual process steps
by dragging and dropping related tasks
onto the graphical workspace then with
the user interface properties they can
transform those process steps into a
visual workflow
users may also use the recorder wizard
in the uipath tool to build web based or
application workflows
the next feature is record and playback
the user can use this function to record
actions and transform them into
automated process series
ui path has the following types of
recording options
basic recording it focuses on automating
single task and is commonly used to
develop each activity's complete
selector
desktop recording it can be used for a
variety of actions as well as actions
development
web recording it is a common tool for
viewing and recording web page
activities
citrix recording it is very widely used
for recording stuff like pictures and
virtualized environment automation
next we have inbuilt activities in
uipath ui path comes with over 300
built-in activities covering a wide
range of process automation and
application integration design tasks
these activities are found in activities
pane which covers most design tasks such
as data extraction data entry and
automation
next we have advanced scraping options
scraping data from web pages and
applications is easier with ui path
screen scraping
furthermore the data screen scraping
wizard helps in scraping of data with a
repetitive structure scraping solution
works flawlessly with any program
including.net java flash pdf legacy and
sap
next we have high security and
robustness we can create super smart
durable robots with uipath
with a simple visual canvas everyone in
the company can use bots
ui path offers high security auto login
functionality to run the bots and
operates with a locked screen allowing
automated process to run in complete
privacy
let's look at the components of uipath
the first component we have ui path
studio uipath robot and uipath
orchestrator
let's look at them one by one this is
how a ui path studio looks like ui patch
studio is a user friendly interface
inside the tool that allows user to
visually plan and design various
automation process through diagrams
using drag and drop functionality these
diagrams are merely a structural
reflection of specific tasks that must
be completed
this is the activity pane in the ui path
studio
it consists of project activities and
snippets
this is the ribbon tab it consists of
saving options opening new files
debugging files recording screen
scraping data scraping and many more we
will explore this in the demo section
next we have output pane where output is
being displayed
and we have the properties pane where
the properties of each activity is shown
here
the next component is ui path robot
after you have built your process the
next move is to put into action in the
uipath studio
uipath robots are used to translate the
process into tasks which are then
executed
these robots are used to assign various
tasks and carry them out in the same
manner as humans but without human
interference
when given operation occurs on the
computer ui path robots are programmed
to begin executing tasks automatically
next we have uipath orchestrator
the orchestrator is a web-based
application in uipath it has features
like deploying monitoring scheduling and
controlling automated bots and process
it's a centralized forum for managing
and controlling all software bots
let's look at the architecture of uipath
it consists of two sections the client
side and the server side and the three
layers
let us look at them one by one we will
first look at decline side and the
server side
client-side ui path components are those
that the user or developer can
communicate with directly uipath studio
uipath robot browser and uipath agent
are usually included
ui paths back and operation are
considered server-side the tasks and
workflows that a user produces are saved
in the databases uipath orchestrator
chooses the necessary function and
software robots to carry out the code's
task
the robot's locks and statistics are
stored in the back end locks are useful
for analyzing robot performance and
detecting errors in them the two
elements comprise the ui path robot
agent support for ui path and the
executor service for uipath the agent
support for ui path is a service in ui
path that serves as the mediator between
the client side and the server side of
ui path all of the information and data
are conveyed via the handler
messages are also logged into the
orchestrator before being moved to the
sql server the service can be used to
search all of the currently available
tasks in the device tray it also can
change device settings and start and
stop the current task
execute a service for uipath in this the
software robots use this service to
carry out the tasks specified in the
windows session
now let us look at the three layers
first one is the presentation layer this
ui path components that are open to the
users make up the client layer ui path
studio robots browsers ui path agent and
executors for example a user or
developer may use these components to
design and create different tasks that
can be automated computer robots are
commonly used to complete this task the
client layer is an another name for the
presentation layer
let us look at the service layer the
uipath's architecture's most significant
sheet the cloud layer shows all server
information the uipath orchestrator is
the most significant part of the server
layer when the robots can perform the
task the entire project is periodically
uploaded to the server within the aid of
an orchestrator the project is often
carried out through several structures
the orchestrator is in charge of the
whole band it keeps track of the project
development schedules software robots
for execution and produces summary
reports based on the filtered parameter
it assists in the synchronization of
software robots so that they can
continue to perform routine tasks it
helps our project meet project
requirements service levels and
deadlines thanks to its web-based
management system
now let us look at the persistence layer
database servers make up the bulk of
this sheet during this layer all of the
robot's configuration information is
saved users insert data robots assigned
tasks logging information and assets
among the other items into the
orchestrators configuration details
furthermore persistency layer is in
charge of keeping the log information
updated by the uipath agent services
elasticsearch is used to store these
locks the locks are primarily useful for
locating and correcting errors
process level data is usually saved in
relational database management system
such as sql server this makes processing
logs from the vast volume of data a lot
simpler
hence the queues tasks are often taken
care by the persistency layer
let's look at some of the applications
of uipath
in sales in sales ui path is used to
generate invoice this is an example of
data replication in action both crm and
accounting systems must have the same
sales details bots can update accounting
records prepare and send invoices from
the appropriate email addresses instead
of manually replicating data
it is also used in keeping scorecards up
to date companies that do not have hr
and crm systems integrated can use rpa
bots to ensure that crm adjustments are
submitted to scorecards in real time
allowing sales reps to track their
progress
it is used in crm updating a new class
of solution is evolving to incorporate
their email call and other contact data
into crm a simple bot could be written
to update your crm records with customer
contact information if you can't find a
suitable solution for using the crm
systems
next it is used in banking in banking it
is used to check kyc
though dedicated kyc solutions are
evolving rba bots can be used to
automate portions of the kyc process if
your organization does not want to use
one
a case may be referred to an employee in
the event of an edge case that requires
human involvement
it is used in sanction of loans like
most document process activities this
method is appropriate to rpa automation
because complex business logic can be
embedded in bots which can partially
automate loan decisions and the manual
process that follow
it is used in execution of trade rpa
bots may be useful in situations where
legacy systems are incapable of storing
complex limit orders
however this is more a band-aid solution
in the long run switching to a
sophisticated and competent trading
system will certainly be a smart
investment considering how it could
increase trading and minimize trader
workload
next it is used in healthcare
in healthcare it is used for appointment
scheduling
the rpa bot makes appointment for
patient based on their diagnosis doctor
availability location and other factors
such as financial statements
it is used in ucla supporting analytics
to implementation treatment
rpa
they collect a variety of medical
information
to provide more reliable diagnosis and
better patient care without violating
any confidentiality regulation
let's look at the benefits of uipath now
this class that i have registered for
increased productivity as soon as uipath
automates with quick speed and
accessibility on your machine consider
an rpa board that allows a worker to
produce a monthly reporting
assessment instead of manually
could increase as a result of process
automation
next we have high efficiency rps
software does not need a break it can
operate 24 hours a day a single rpa
robot may replace two to five full time
workers if not more robots can do the
same amount of work in less time or more
work at the same time than humans
customer experience in rpa adopted
business
routine and repetitive and boring tasks
are assigned to robots allowing
employees to focus more on customer
service company may meet consumer needs
with the help of professional and
knowledgeable employees
highly secure there is no risk of
information leakage from one component
to another because it performs single
task as a result data access is strictly
monitored and reported
cost effective ui path has minimal
operating cost and more efficient use of
i.t resources
let's look at the top companies hiring
ui part developers
infosys
ibm
deloitte ey
kpmg tata tech mahindra and capgemini
let's look at the salary trends for ui
part developers
the average pay scale for a ui part
developer in india is 5 lakh 45 000
rupees
uipath developer salary ranges from 362
000 rupees to 1 million
in usa the ui part developer salary
ranges from 58
two hundred and seven thousand dollars
and the average salary is seventy six
thousand dollars
let's look at a demo
consider a scenario where you have
multiple excel files you want to combine
the data in single file
in this demo we will merge two excel
files into a single excel file and send
it over an email let's create automation
to merge two excel files using uipath
from here we can open a new project or
existing project stored locally or on
version control system
with the click we can open a new project
or create a new project from a template
uipath offers many templates depending
on what you are trying to do
for now let us start with a blank
project
so we'll open a blank project here
so we'll open our main workflow
then we'll go to new and select a new
sequence we can do it using a flowchart
as well but for now i'll show you doing
a sequence
so we'll open the sequence and we'll
name the sequence
since we are merging two files i'll name
it as
merging files
and i'll create it
so we'll go to the activities pane
firstly we need to drag and drop a read
csv activity
so search for read csv
so drag and drop read csv activity
since we are using two excel files so we
need to read csv activities
and read from the file we need to select
the file location
so
we'll select the file location sample
csv file one
and at the file
we'll select another file location
sample csv file
at the output side
we'll create a variable
and name it as sl underscore file y
similarly for another csv
we'll create a variable and name it as
sl underscore
file 2.
so this much is done now we need an
assign activity
so we'll search for assign activity
so we'll drag and drop
assign activity has two parameters two
and enter an expression
so in the 2 we'll create a variable
name name it as
merged
sl and
in the expression
write an expression
say excel underscore
file 1
dot clone
why are we using a clone function the
clone function creates a new data table
with same structure but does not copy
the data
oops it's showing an error here so
what's the error
so
we need to
assign the variable type
to be
system.data.data table
here we go
error has gone
so after using the assign activity we
need to merge the data table so we need
merge data table activity
so search for merge
data table here we go drag and drop it
we need
too much data table activities
so drag and drop
and specify the destination and source
here
destination is the merged excel
and the source is the
sl underscore file one for the first
data merge table
similarly for second merge data table
destination remains same
source will change to sl underscore file
too
so this is done
so next we need to drag and drop a write
csv file
write csv file creates an output file in
which you want to merge the two files
so search for
write csv
here we go drag and drop it
so choose the path create the file
so you can see there is no output file
here so we'll create the output file now
which is an empty file
so output dot csv
so we have created an output file
so right from we'll write it as merged
excel we need the data from merged excel
[Music]
so the output file is created so now we
need to send the file over and mail
so for that we need to drag and drop a
get password activity
so we'll search for get password
activity
here we go drag and drop it
and
once you get this get password activity
enter the password here enter your
password email id password
so there is a prerequisite when you use
get password
to receive a mail go to your google
account in google account go to your
security option and in security there is
an option called less secure app access
turn that on
i'll repeat turn on the less secure app
access
okay
once the get password is done
go to the results section
in the results section right click and
create a variable
name it's something maybe sss
so i've
created a variable there
so we need a last activity now
that is smt mail message
smtp
mail message
drag and drop it
so in the host port and enter this
server
so the server you have to enter it as
smtp
dot gmail
all should be in the double quotes
xmtp
g
and enter the port number as
587
and enter your email id here which is
your own email id i'll enter my
once you enter the email id enter the
password
what we had created
so that's done so enter the email id
here
enter the subject whatever you want
so i will enter it as merged
data
most excel
files
enter the body
so we'll attach the file
so what is the file which we are
attaching
so we are attaching the output file what
we have named it as
output dot csv file
so that's it will run the program
you run the code
sample execution has started
and within the 10 seconds sample
execution has ended
so we'll go and check if we have
received the mail
so this is my email id
here we go we have received the email
here
let's open this let's open the output
file
here we go you can see the data is been
merged
and if you go to the file where the
documents were stored
here you go these were the two files the
sample file one and sample file two and
this is the most file which was created
let me show you the sample file one
and sample file 2.
so this is the sample file 1 with 10
rows
and this is sample file 2
which also has 10 rows
so this is file 2 with 10 rows and file
1 with 10 rows
and here we go this is the
output file
which has
both
10 10 rows merged here
here we go
it is sent over and made
so that's it it was
an example a demo
for better understanding of ui path in
this video we will be looking at the
installation of ui uipath so let us see
the requirements
we will first look at the hardware
requirements
the cpu should at least have a processor
of 1.4 gigahertz 32-bit configuration or
it's recommended to have a 1.8 gigahertz
64-bit configuration
the device is recommended to have a ram
of 8 gb
if not at least a minimum of 4 gb
let us look at the software requirements
if you are using a windows operating
system then windows should be of version
8.1 or 8.1 n or 10 or 10 n and the
windows server should be of 2012 r2 2016
or 2019 versions
another prerequisite is to have dotnet
framework of minimum of 4.5.2 version
installed
let us look at the additions the
different editions that uipath offers ui
path offers two types of editions
community edition and enterprise edition
community edition is for the developers
and small teams who are just starting on
their automation journey the enterprise
edition is further classified into three
types enterprise studio edition
enterprise cloud edition and enterprise
server edition
so enterprise studio edition is for
individual enterprise developers who
want to experiment with ui path studio
price cloud is a cloud-based deployment
of entire rpa enterprise platform for
any size business enterprise server
on-premises deployment for entire
enterprise automation platform for
large-scale business
let us look at the different profiles in
uipath ui path studio x ui path studio
and ui path studio pro ui studio ax is
for business users if you are not a
developer but if you want to automate a
simple task then it is easy to use a
studio x
uipath studio it is for rpl developers
build complex automation that is run by
attended or unattended robots
uipath studio pro it is for specialized
developers automate with ai advanced rpa
features testing tools and sophisticated
coding services
so we will look at the installation
let us install ui path
go to any one of the browser and search
for uipath.com
this will take you to the official ui
path website
here you can see try ui path for free
click here
since i have already registered before
it is showing as continue to existing
organization
if you are visiting this website for the
first time
then you might have to register or sign
in using an email account
after signing in and filling all the
details you can continue
here you can see download ui path studio
click on this
and
download the ui path studio
here you go the ui path studio setup
file is getting downloaded
once the ui path file is downloaded run
the setup file and here you can see the
ui path is getting installed after
installation it will ask for a license
select community license which is free
after selecting the license you need to
choose a profile there are three
profiles ui patch studio pro which is
the advanced studio ide it has features
like testing tools advanced rpa features
and coding services
another profile is ui path studio
it is for developers who have pure
programming experience
and the last profile is the ui path
studio x it is for the people who don't
have any programming experience
so we will select ui path studio x for
now next ui path will ask you to update
the channel you can either select the
stable version or preview version
we will select the stable version for
now
after you select the versions you need
to select the source control plugins you
can enable git version control system or
apache sub version
and azure develop server
ui path provides a
short introduction video tutorials to
learn how to build automations following
step by step instructions and an academy
to take free training on the uipath
academy
so that's it you have successfully
installed uipath studio
from here you can open a new project new
template and start building the first
automation
so what is ui path
now rpa is a technology with which human
tasks can be automated
to facilitate this a tool is required
uipath is one such tool among others
that are used to create bots with the
help of visual processes and diagrams
it provides complete end-to-end
automation
calling it hyper automation
ui path was founded by daniel dynes and
mario sterka in 2005.
uipath is specially used for windows
process automation
it automates repetitive tasks
and lastly
uipath offers drag and drop
functionalities to make it easy to use
now since there are so many other tools
like blue prism automation anywhere in
the market what makes ui path stand out
so let's look at the advantages of
uipath
first
uipath has an activity library
this library has several built-in
activities and features like display
message
input box and so on
this improves the customer experience
we will deal with these activities in
the demo later
next up
is security
rpa deals with a variety of information
like credit card numbers financial
information and passwords
uipath offers extensive securities since
all the information can be encrypted and
stored under a centralized server has an
activity library up next we have
recorders
so ui path uses a micro recorder to
record the user actions such as mouse
clicks and keystrokes
once the actions are recorded
they can be emulated using emulators for
quick automation
third-party integration
uipath can be integrated with
third-party plugins like ibm watson and
google plugins
then we have powerful debugging
uipath studio comes with a debug
component that helps find and locate
problems easily in complex workflows
this is useful for viewing the execution
of each activity to verify what data it
gets and if there are errors in
producing outputs
now let's understand the various ui path
products
first up is uipath studio
this is the platform to create the bots
this product consists of all the
necessary drag and drop activities and a
robust ui to help develop bots of your
choice now the ui part studio consists
of the gui dashboard it offers a visual
dashboard with activities like send
email display message and so on
then we have types of recorders uipath
studio offers various types of recorders
to record actions on multiple platforms
then we have logging and exception
handling it offers various options for
debugging and exception handling such as
debug robust open logs to help doorstep
etc and finally
we have reusable components
the user can create reusable components
to publish them together as libraries
next we have the ui path robots
all the automation tasks that created
are run by uipath robots
there are two types of robots
attended robots and unattended robots
attended robots
work with you to speed up service desk
and help desk
it is used in activities where human
involvement is the key
unattended robots operate without human
touch maximizing cost and performance
benefits for any variety of back office
tasks
lastly
we have the uipath orchestrator
the orchestrator is like a centralized
entity where you can deploy
secure manage all your automation tasks
here are the steps involved
first
you create a bot now you create a
project and publish it as a process for
further use
once a process is created it is assigned
to a specific robot to execute in an
environment
this collectively constitutes a job
now let's move on to the architecture of
uipath
so on the top
you have the client layer consisting of
uipath studio and the uipath robot
now the uipath robot has two parts
one is the uipath agent service which
displays all the available jobs in the
system tray and the other one is the
uipath executor service which is used to
run the jobs in one windows session
the server layer receives the robot once
it is ready for execution with the help
of the orchestrator you can run the
project on different pcs
the orchestrator monitors the deploys
configures queue management and logging
lastly we have the persistent layer
which consists of the databases
it takes care of the queues and holds
information about the robot
configuration and their assigned
processes
now that we know what ui path is let's
acquaint ourselves with its user
interface and understand its components
better hello everyone this so this is
what the typical interface looks like
talking about big data first we have the
ripper required with an exit consists of
three tabs
home design and debug
home is where you start a new project
from pre-defined templates or open a
project you recently worked on by
default the projects are created in the
location shown below
next is the design tab
design tab
adds sequences flowcharts and state
machines to your project it installs and
manages activity packages
it builds interactions with ui elements
and then publishes your work to
orchestrator
finally is debug
it debugs your workflow while using
debugging tools to set up breakpoints
monitor the execution of activity step
by step and adjust the debugging speed
next on the screen is tools
so the tools tab can be used for
installing extensions from
firefox edge java silverlight citrix and
windows remote desktop and is also used
for launching the ui explorer and
project dependencies mass update tool
then we have settings
the settings tab has options for
changing the interface language
setting global preferences and managing
activity so let's start off before we
move on to general settings then there
is settings for design locations managed
resources and finally license and
profile
up next you have help
the help tab directs you to product
documentation
online resources community forum and the
rpa
the recorder component in uipath studio
allows the user to record ui mouse
movements and keyboard activities to
generate automation scripts
after that
you have scraping
so uipath studio supports two types of
scraping one is screen scraping and the
next one is data scraping
so screen scraping is programmatic
collection of visual data and data
scraping is the extraction of structured
data from an application
then you have user events
user events records events such as mouse
clicks and keystrokes
then you have variables so variables
hold different types of data
these variables can change over time
uipath makes an easy provision to create
and remove unused variables
on the bottom left you have project
so the project panel enables you to view
the components of the current project
add folders open the file location
manage dependencies and adjust project
settings
beside it
you have activities panel
so the activities panel shows available
activities that can be added to the
current workflow users can use the
search box to find activities navigate
through them
using navigation keys and press
you also have the snippets panel which
enables you to easily reuse automation
it includes by default
multiple samples and snippets
to the bottom right you have the
properties panel which is contextual and
enables you to view and change the
properties of a selected activity
you also have the outline panel which
displays the project hierarchy all
available variables and nodes
you can highlight activities in this
panel by selecting them in the designer
panel
the output panel enables you to display
among other things
exceptions for packages are also
displayed
so now that you have understood the
interface of uipath let's look at the
companies using uipath
so you have accenture capgemini
cognizant ethos and deloitte to name a
few
now
we'll do a demo to automate a task using
uipath
studio so here is what we are going to
do in the demo
we will create an automated process to
fetch data from a website wherein the
bot would extract data like the name of
the person the phone number and the
email id
this data will store it in an excel seat
and send it over an email
now let's get started
digitally transfers through the stem
organizations we'll be using the fake
name generator website to generate
random data of people and store this
data set in an excel sheet jimmy if i
had to do this manually i would first
create an excel sheet so let me open an
excel workbook
i'll create a blank workbook
so this is where i'll put my data if i
had to do it manually
so now let me take you to
the fake name generator website
so i'll search for
fakenamegenerator.com
so this is the website where you can
generate
fake names
now
if i had to store this transformation in
excel
i would manually copy paste each and
every detail
and paste it onto the excel sheet
first i had to create columns like name
then
phone number
this in
an email
after that
i had to come back
to this
and
copy each of these fields
and how you can become a certified
digital take the phone number let's
answer the most important so i would
copy this
and similarly for the email address as
well
for one record it is fine
what if you are asked to fetch 100
records or say 200 records
then this method is not at all feasible
it is time consuming and inefficient
you need to find a way where you can
automate this task of fetching records
ui path is a solution for this
so let's see how we can automate this
task using the uipath studio
so i'll click on open
main workflow
first
we need to direct ui path to go to the
fake name generator website
for that
we need the sequence activity
so let me search for sequence here
under
what is expected
and
i'll drag it
here
after that i need to open the website in
a web browser
so for that
let me search for another activity
called open browser so under activity
i look for
open browser
so i'll drag it on the sequence itself
now
it is asking you to insert the url of
the website
and it must be within double quotes
url within double quotes rather than
all that
welcome to this brand new local server
we need to select the name of the
browser where you want to open this
website
so under input and browser type
i'll choose
chrome
now let me go ahead and run this file
so
under debug
i have run file
i'll click on it
so as you can see the website is
automatically opened in a new window on
chrome
i'll close this
the next step in the process is to tell
the program how many records we want to
fetch from the website
for this
we will create an input dialog box
so
bridge choose under activities explain
and it's very simple i'll search for the
source input bucket
so here you get the input dialog box
i'll drag and drop it on the top
now
it is asking us to give the details so
i'll
put it within double quotes say enter
the
details of customers
or say
people
and then here
i'll give enter the
number of
records you want to fetch
now
now i have to store this information in
a variable
so under variables
i'll create a variable and name it as
total
is the total number of records i want to
fetch
similarly
under output result i'll give the same
variable name as total
now we need to fetch the details a
number of times repeatedly say for 10
times or 20 times or 50 times
to do this operation
i'll be using a do while loop
so to use a do while loop
i'll first search for
do while
and i'll drop it to the
do section of the sequence
as you can see
do while has two components
one is the body
and the other one is condition
the body has the things that you want
the program to do
the condition is where you evaluate
certain conditions every time when the
program has to do a task
so for every step or iteration
it will check if the condition is true
or not
and go inside the body of the loop
now for doing this
we need to assign a variable
so
let's name the variable as
val
and i'll change the variable type to
integer
and i'll make the scope to sequence
i'll also assign a default value of 0.
now we'll compare this val to the
variable total
so the condition i will give is check
if val is less than total
so under
condition i'll give val
less than
total
so every time the value of val is less
than the total
it will keep fetching the records from
the website
you can see it has thrown some error
now this is because
our total variable is of type string
while the val variable is of type
integer
so you can't compare an integer
with a string variable
so that would be absurd
we need to convert the total variable to
an integer using the same function
so here itself i'll write
c int which is convert this total
variable to integer
you can see the error is gone
the next thing i want to do is if the
value of the valve variable is less than
total
i'll increment the value of val to 1.
so to do that
i'll use an activity called assign
so i'll check for
assign
and i'll drag it on to the body
so here i'll give
val
equals to
val
plus one
this will make sure the value of val
increases by one every time there is a
new record inserted
it will continue until the value of val
no longer matches the total
so the next job is to extract
information from the website
to do this we will use the get full text
activity
so i'll search for get full text here
and i'll
drag it right below the assign activity
now
you need to select the information which
you want so first i want to get the name
i'll click on the indicate element
inside browser
and then select the name of the person
so i'll click on this
and
i click on the name
there you go
now
we need to store this name in a variable
so i'll create a variable
so under variable i'll create
a variable called name
and
in the output also
i'll give the same variable
name next
i want to fetch the phone number of the
person
so i'll again select get full text
and i'll drag it
here
i'll click on indicate element inside
browser
so i'll scroll down
and i'll select the phone number of the
person
so we have
selected the phone number
similarly i'll store this phone number
in a variable
so i'll create a variable called
phone underscore number
and
the output text box also will
give the same variable
as
phone underscore number
after that i want to get the email
address of the person
so i'll continue with the same drill
i'll select the activity once again
which is get full text and i'll drag it
right here
i'll click on indicate element inside
browser
and now
we'll select the email address which is
this one
similarly
i'll store the email address in a
variable called
email underscore id
and in the output also we'll give the
same variable name which is email
underscore id
now
we need to store the names phone numbers
and email ids into an excel seat
for that we need to create a data table
so i'll search for data table under
activities
let me go ahead and do that
so i'll
choose build data table and drag it
right below the input dialog box
now this table has to be assigned to a
variable
so let me do that
let me give a variable name as
fetch
underscore data underscore table
similarly
the output also will give the same
variable name which is
fetch underscore data underscore table
one thing i need to tell you here is
we change the variable
type so i'll select browse for types
and
look for data table
which is
system.data
i'll drill down
and search for data table which is this
one
click ok
we need to assign the column names to
this data table
so let me now do that
i'll
uncheck all this and select the columns
so you will give the first column name
as
name itself
click on ok
select one more column
give it as
phone number
click ok
and then
we need the email address
i'll hit ok
so we are done
so first the data table is created and
then we'll write this data to an excel
file
after that
we need to create rows for the data
table
for that
i will search for row
under activities
i will search for row
and
i'll select
add row
i'll select add data row
i'll place it right below where we have
created all the variables
now i want to add a row for the name
phone number and email address
so under
input i'll select
array row
i'll expand this
and within curly braces
i'll give my variable names
so those would be
name
give a comma
and then
phone underscore number
comma
email
underscore id
click ok
i made a mistake it should be within
curly braces
okay
now to tell the table to which it should
write the rows to we need to assign
under the data table name
so under data table
i'll give
fetch underscore data underscore table
for every iteration
a record will be added to the table
then
we need to refresh the page to extract
the next set of information
so for that
i will add another activity called click
and drop it right below the add data row
so under activities
i'll search for
click
and i'll select
mouse click
and i'll drop it
right
below this one
now we need to indicate where do we want
to click from the browser
so
click on this
go on top
and
select
generate
so we want to click on generate
next i will write the data to a csv file
so i'll search for
write csv under activities
and
i'll drop it towards the
end of the sequence
right here
now you need to give the location where
you want to place this file on your
system
and give the source from where it will
take the information
so
let's give the location where you want
to place this file
i'll place it on my desktop itself
i'll name this as
fetch
save it
and
for the source
i'll give
fetch underscore data underscore table
we are all set now let's run it
so under debug file i'll select
run file
i'll
enter the number of records so let me
fetch 10 records
click on ok
now this might take some time
i believe it has run successfully now
let me check for my csv file
that should ideally be on my desktop
there you go so we have the csv file let
me open it
you can see it has extracted
10 rows of data
and three columns namely
name of the person the phone number and
the email address
so we are done with the first task of
automatically generating data from a
website
the next task is to send this file
over email now to send an email
you need the smtp activity
so under
activities i'll search for smtp
i'll drag it right below here
now we need to configure this
i'll be actually sending this email from
someone else's email id to my email id
so under 2
i'll give my email address
which is
within quotes i'll type abhijit dot
at
simplylearn.net
i'll give a subject
as
automatic
data
extraction
under body i'll give something like hi
please find a test
now we have to attach the file
we have to give the location of the file
here
so
let me go to
properties
and
i'll select this
cancel
[Music]
paste this here
followed by
the file name which is
fetch
dot csv
i'll click on ok
after that
i have to give the host port number
which is 465
and
the
and the server name
which is smtp.gmail.com
under log on i'll give the sender's
email id
i have to give the password as well
under the receiver it's my email id
which is ibg.business
for the sender i'll give the email ids
chin my dot this pandey at
simplylearn.net
and i'll give a dummy name
so we are almost done
let me now go to debug file and run this
it is asking to enter the number of
records i will give 5 click on ok
this will take some time so let's just
wait
so we have successfully run our program
now let me check my inbox if i have got
any mail from
chinmay
so there you go
i've got this email
and below you can see
the fetch.csv file attached and it has
five rows
what is ui path orchestrator
uipath orchestrator is a web application
that allows you to orchestrate the
execution of repetitive business process
by uipath robots
orchestrator manages the creation
monitoring scheduling and controlling of
automated bots and process
it serves as a point of integration for
third party solutions and applications
it's a centralized forum for managing
and controlling all software boards
it can manage the entire robot fleet
let's look at the orchestrated
capabilities
provisioning provisioning establishes
and maintains the connection between the
robots and the web application
deployment deployment ensures that the
correct package versions are delivered
to the assigned robots for execution
configuration
configuration looks after the
maintenance and delivery of the robot
environments and process configuration
queues
queues ensures that the workload is
distributed automatically across robots
monitoring monitoring manages user
permissions and keeps track of robot
recognition details
logging
logging locks are stored and indexed in
a sql database
interconnectivity
interconnectivity functions as a
centralized contact point for third
party solutions or applications
let's look at the orchestrator use cases
the strength of uipath orchestrator
comes from its ability to control the
entire robot fleet
let's look at the different use cases
the first
is attended
this type of robot is activated by user
events and operates at the same
workstation as a human
orchestrator is used with attended
robots to provide a centralized process
deployment and logging medium
unattended in virtual environments
robots can run unattended and automate a
variety of process
the orchestrator is in charge of remote
execution control scheduling and support
for work use in addition to the attended
robot capabilities
studio or studio x they have unattended
robot capabilities but it should only be
used to connect your studio or studio x
to the orchestrator for creation
purposes
non-production robots are similar to
unattended robots but they can only be
used for research and development
attended unattended non-production
studio and studio x robots can all be
operated from a single location let's
look at the orchestrator user interface
dashboard enables us to see charts and
statistics illustrating usage
information for all the orchestrator
components like process
assets
queues schedules robots jobs and
transactions
let's look at the tenant context to view
and control the tenant level entities in
your orchestrator pick tenant from the
sidebar menu
with only one instance of the
orchestrator multi-tenancy allows you to
isolate data
these features help you to automate
various departments within your
organization while also ensuring that
orchestrated data is approved according
to your preferences
please bear in mind that all of the
information is contained in this same
database
let's look at the components one by one
robots
a robot is an execution host that runs
ui pass studio process
you can add robots edit them display the
status and license state adjust the
environment they are assigned to and
change the runtime settings on the
robots tab you can also see the logs
that a single robot has created
process can be downloaded and executed
automatically by robots using custom
settings
while building or editing a robot you
can configure automatic process
downloading logging level font smoothing
and resolution in the settings tab
folders
folders give you a fine grain control
over automation and their associated
organizations as well as staff through
the entire organization in the
orchestrator there are two types of
folders classic and modern classic
folders functionality is allowed by
default while modern folders
functionality must be enabled by the
host or the tenant administrator
users
a user is an individual with access
dependent capabilities whose view and
control of the orchestrator are
determined by the access rights granting
users can be developed and managed
either locally in the orchestrator or an
external directory
roles
in orchestrator the roles tab help you
to handle user permissions the
orchestrator view that a consumer has is
defined by the role they have been
assigned
a function allows you to control view
edit create and delete permissions on
all orchestrator pages and modules
machines
a machine page allows you to provision
and control machines in preparation for
registering robots with the orchestrator
it lists all of the machines that are
currently in operation as well as their
forms
it allows you to create your computer
whether it's standard or a template
packages
all projects published from ui patch
studio and those manually imported are
displayed on the packages tab you can
display all available versions of any
package on the packages tab as well as
the status claims and release notes if
they are available
ml skills
ml skills retrieves and request machine
learning skills from the ai fabric
service
it authenticates the robot that is
running the machine learning skills
audit
the audit page shows the audit trail for
all acts taken by orchestrator entities
several criteria including component
user action and time can be used to
filter the data on the audit page
credential stores
a credential store is named location
inside a safe store such as cyber arc
where you can get robot credentials and
credential assets when you need them at
the tenant stage orchestrator encourages
the users of several credential stores
webhooks
webhooks make it easier to integrate
your ui path automation with the rest of
your app ecosystem
you can subscribe to the orchestrator
events and have them sent to the
external dcm bpm or crm solutions to
notify various users about the new queue
items that can be processed cause
failures or process updates
license
robot licensing is available both at the
host and the tenant level in the
orchestrator on the license list
this enables you to shorten your
deployment time and handle activation
from a single location
within a single click you can trigger
renew delete and delegate licenses
alerts notifications for robots queue
objects triggers tasks procedures and
activities are shown on the alerts tab
you will receive updates from all of
your folders on this tab
and you will not be able to choose more
granular options
alerts are sent in real time and can be
categorized as info success warn error
or fatal
settings
you can adjust various settings on the
settings tab
including the time zone email warning
information account information package
feeds and interactive authentication now
let us look with respect to the folder
context from the sidebar menu pick any
available folder to view and control the
entities within that folder
automations contains the following tabs
process
jobs triggers and locks
the process page allows you to build new
process from uploaded packages
manage existing process and keep all of
your process up to date with the latest
package versions
this allows you to spread packages
through the entire organization users
and robots and execute process more
quickly from the jobs tasks
jobs on an uipath robot a job represents
the execution of a procedure
the execution of a job can be started in
either attended or unattended mode on
attended robots you can't run a job from
the orchestrator and they can't run
under a locked computer
triggers
triggers allow you to run jobs in a
predefined sequence
at predetermined intervals and if new
products are added to your queues
logs the locks page shows you all of the
robot locks in all of the folders you
have access to
to access the locks tab you must have
view permission on the locks
locks are kept in the local database if
the orchestrator is in accessible
monitoring monitoring contains the
following tabs machines process
queues and sla
machines displays information about all
the existing run times on an aggregate
basis and allows you to check the
overall health of each runtime
process
the process page allows you to build new
process from the uploaded packages
managing existing process and keep all
of your process up to date
queues
a queue is a storage container that can
accommodate an infinite number of
objects multiple types of data such as
invoice information or customer
information may be stored in queue
objects other systems such as sap or
salesforce
can be used to process this data
by default the data stored in and output
from the queue items is in free form sla
displays sla and risk sla information
for all queues in the current folder
with sla predictions allowed
this allows you to determine if the
newly added queue items will be
processed on time and if so what
resources you will need to devote to
ensure that their sla is not violated
when the sla is in danger of not being
reached you will be adequately informed
so that you can make the required
changes
queues
use contains the following tabs queues
and review request
in the queues pages click on the review
request tab to show revision request the
page shows items in different queues
that have been allocated for revision
assets
assets are usually shared variables or
credentials that can be used through
several automation projects
they allow you to store unique
information that the robots can easily
access
storage buckets
rpa developers may use storage buckets
to provide a per folder storage solution
when building automation projects
the storage buckets page shows you your
current bucket configuration and allows
you to build as many new storage buckets
as you need
testing
testing contains the following tabs test
sets
test cases test execution test schedules
and test data queues
test said
a test set is a collection of any number
of individual test cases
each intended to serve a specific
function
the test sets page list of few currently
available test sets and allows you to
build new tests updating existing ones
and run them
test cases
the test cases page shows all of your
test cases from all of your projects and
app versions in one place
these are the test cases that are used
in and to make up your test sets
test executions
your previously executed test sets and
their information are shown on the test
execution tab since test sets are often
subject to change
test executions act as an immutable
record of any given test sets execution
at a given point in time
test schedules allow you to run test at
predetermined intervals and in a
scheduled manner
test data queues
using test data queues you can store and
manage your test data
the test data queue serves as a
container for queue items that are ready
to be consumed via various activities
the test data queue items are uploaded
or deleted based on the first in first
out concept
action catalogs
task catalogs are task containers that
allow you to categorize your task using
a variety of criteria
the catalog where a task is stored is
defined when the task is created using
studio's build type task operation
in orchestrator the catalog must be
specified first
if you mention a catalog that has not
been generated in orchestrator the task
is created in orchestrator without a
catalog
settings
setting contains two tabs permissions
and machine permission
a user is an individual with access
dependent capabilities
whose view and control of the
orchestrator are determined by the roles
assigned to them
users may be installed locally in the
orchestrator or an external directory
machines
you can use the machines page to
provision and manage system entities
which you can then use to bind uipath
robots to the orchestrator
it lists all of the machines that are
currently in use as well as the types
machines are global tools which means
they can be accessed from any folder
let's look at the demo in this demo we
will see how to connect uipath robot
with the orchestrator
how to run workflow using the
orchestrator
let's go to the browser
in the browser enter platform.ui
this will take you to the uipath.com
website
if you have already an account sign in
enter the password
click on sign
meanwhile
open the ui path assistant
so this is the uipath assistant so
uipath robot is a kind of representative
which runs the workflow
so we create a workflow in the ui path
studio then we upload it on the cloud
orchestrator then we configure different
robots to run this workflow
now that we have logged in to the
orchestrator
go to the admin
so you need to click here to add tenant
for the ui path community free edition
you can add only one tenant so i have
already created a tenant so this option
is disabled for me so when you click on
the add tenant for the first type the
tenant window will be displayed then
fill the tenant name password and
confirm the password and it will ask you
for name surname and email address which
is optional
so after filling the details click on
provision the tenant and lieutenant
admin are created and displayed in the
tenants page
so as you can see the tenant is created
there is an option here users and groups
you can go to the users and you can see
the different users
so this is my user
this is me
now you can go to the groups
and see the different groups allocated
and their licenses
so now that we have created a tenant
i have named it an entire segment
let's open it
meanwhile you can open ui path assistant
open ui path assistant
this is the uipath robot there are two
different ways to connect robot to the
orchestrator one is signing in the ui
path assistant it will get the token
from the ui path orchestrator by user
authentication and it will directly
connect machine and the robot and the
other way is to manually connect
so we'll sign in
enter the password
now you can see here robot is connected
to the orchestrator
so when you sign in the robot will get
connected to the orchestrator you can go
here in the preferences
go to the orchestrator settings and you
can see connected and licensed
so
let's go to the orchestrator
in the orchestrator go to the tenant
context
and here you can see the robot is
connected it's enabled
if you go to the machines
you can see the machine is also
connected
so you can see here
there is an unattended robot here
so to get this unattended robot what you
have to do is go to the users
select the user which you are using this
is my username
go to edit
and here
you should
enable this unattended robot
enable this option and enter the
username to get the username you can
open the command prompt and enter who am
i so you will get the user name copy
paste the username enter the password
and click on update
and the unattended robot will get
created
so
that is how you create the unattended
robot
now that we have connected robot to the
orchestrator let's open the ui patch
studio we'll create a workflow and then
we'll run it using the robot
so now we have opened the ui path studio
let's open a blank process
after opening the ui path studio
click on open main workflow
first we'll drag and drop a sequence
then we need a input dialog box
we'll drag and drop input dialog box
enter our title
let's say we'll enter it as
uipath orchestrator
enter the input label
we'll enter it as enter your name
let the input type be as text box
let's create a variable
say we'll name it as name
and let the variable type be string and
the scope is in the sql scope
we have created the variable
so the value entered should be
the variable view
now we'll drag and drop message box
premise set should be displayed
so you enter a caption for the message
say
welcome
and enter the text
let's say hi
and we need to concatenate it
with the
variable names
will say thanks for
watching
this video
so here we go we have created a workflow
now we need to publish this in the
orchestrator so you can see our option
here called publish click on the publish
button
so you can see the package name the
version
the new version
and all the other things click on the
publish button
so the workflow is successfully
published
so the name is blank process 3 and
version is 1.0.60
so let's go to the orchestrator
in orchestrator
go to the my workflow
folder context in this go to my packages
if you go here you can see refresh it
so here you can see blank process 3
so process what we did now
it was published 3 minutes ago
let's go to the process
and the version
what we published was 1.0.16
so
the name was blank process 3. let's
start the job
you can change the job priority we'll
keep it as normal the other things is
default the process name and the job
type
let's let's execute this process one
time
click on start
as you can see command send for blank
process 3
so here you can see it is getting run
here you can see
it is asking for uipath orchestrator
what we entered title and enter your
name
let's enter some name say sam
will click ok
so hi sam thanks for watching this video
there you go the message is being
displayed
like normally in ui patch studio we
click on the run button and run the
workflow but here we have published it
in the orchestrator and through the
orchestrator through the robot we are
running it and the message is displayed
what is framework and its purpose
the framework is intended to serve as a
blueprint for users to create process
that provide at a bare minimum a way to
store interpret and easily change
project configuration data as well as
robot exception handling scheme and
event logging for all exceptions and
related transaction information
the system locks messages at each
relevant stage in the process of
resolving a business transaction and
sends those logs to the orchestrator
server
this in turn can be linked to the elk
stack which is elastic search log stack
and kibana platform which allows for
data storage and a variety of different
ways to represent the data
the purpose of our framework is to
resolve a set of business transaction
a transaction is a small amount of data
and the steps needed to process it to
complete a segment of business process a
process that reads a single email from a
mailbox and extracts data from it is a
good example
what is a business process
the sum of actions by which the data
required for a series of transactions is
collected processed and input into or
out of an it resource is referred to as
a business process
we can classify business process into
three groups based on the steps involved
and how they are repeated
linear
the steps of linear process are only
done once and if different data needs to
be processed the automation must be run
again
iterative the steps of iterative process
are repeated several times but different
data items are used every time
transactional transactional systems like
iterative process have steps that
replicate several times over various
data objects
what is re framework
the robotic enterprise framework is a
state machine based project template
the template includes several
ready-to-use state containers for
launching applications retrieving data
processing it and closing the
transaction
these states are linked together by a
series of transactions that cover almost
every requirement in a typical
automation scenario
several workflows have been triggered
each of which deals with a different
aspect of project
it's designed to incorporate all of the
industry's best practices for logging
exception management application
initialization and other areas
showing it to handle even the most
complex business situations
let's look at the features of re
framework
the three features are settings logging
and business application exception
settings
during the initialization phase of
several process some configuration
settings and configuration values are
frequently read
like urls to the web application
orchestrator queue names and default
logging messages
the re framework maintains the track of
this information by reading it from a
configuration file and storing it in a
different dictionary object shared by
all states instead of updating workflows
directly this provides a simple way to
manage projects by adjusting values in
the configuration file
logging
the built-in locking mechanism is
another helpful feature of re framework
a majority of system workflows use log
message activities to output information
about what is happening at each stage of
execution
this can be used to not only identify
problems and aid in the debugging
process but also to generate
visualization and reports about the
process execution like how many invoices
are handled every day how many failures
occur and what are the critical causes
of this failure
business and application execution
there may be conditions that occur
during the execution of most process
that are not part of the usual execution
flow and must be resolved to achieve
more efficient automation
if the issue can be resolved by
restarting application the framework
will do so automatically and attempt to
process the transaction again such
exceptions are known as application
exception
if the issue is with the data or an
underlying business requirement the
system skips the transaction and moves
to the next such exception are known as
business exception
let's look at the re framework
architecture
the rb framework is implemented as a
state machine which is a form of
workflow with two advantageous
characteristics states and transitions
actions to be taken in response to the
stated input are described by states
transitions that switch the execution
from one state to another based on the
results of the state there are four key
states in re framework that is initial
state
get transaction data process transaction
and end process
initial state initialization this is the
point at which the procedure begins it's
an event where the process initializes
the settings and runs application test
to ensure that all of the prerequisites
for the process start are met
so initialization transitions so there
are two transition system exception and
successful when system exception
when a system error is not nothing it
gets transition to the end process if we
have an application exception during the
initialization phase we don't have
enough details to start the process as a
result we are going to the end process
state to wrap it up
successful when a system error is
nothing it gets transition to get
transaction data if during the
initialization we have no error then we
go to the get transaction data
the next state is the get transaction
state
this date retrieves the next transaction
object this can be a queue item or a
collection item
transaction items are queue items by
default but this can be modified to meet
your needs this is also the state where
the developer can set the condition to
exit the state when there are no items
to process
get transaction data transitions there
are two transitions no data and new
transaction
no data if the transaction item is
nothing then we are at the end of our
data collection so we go to the end
process
new transaction data if the transaction
item contains data then we process it
next state is the process transaction
state
the process transaction state for the
transaction item obtained in the
previous step it performs actions and
applies logic in various application
if a transaction item has been processed
the process moves on to the next
transaction item that is available
so there are three process transaction
transitions
success business exception and system
exception in success if the condition is
business rule exception is nothing and
system error is nothing then the
transition to get transaction data if
there is a business rule exception it is
logged and we move on to the next
transition
business exception if the business rule
exception is not nothing then it gets
transition to get transaction data if we
have a business rule exception we log it
and move to the next transaction by
going to the get transaction data state
system exception if we have an
application exception we close all
programs kill them if they fail to
complete take a screenshot at the moment
the exception happened and go to init
where we re-initialize our working
environment and begin a new form of
transaction that has failed
and finally we have the end process date
the procedure is completed and the
application opened during the automation
are closed in the end process state
since this is the last state the final
state there are no transition available
in the end process state
we'll explore each one of these states
in detail in the demo let's see the demo
now
in this demo we will see how to dispatch
data from the excel file
then we will create queue items and
process these items and then we will
understand the working of each state in
the robotic enterprise framework in
detail
so let's get started
first we'll go to the orchestrator and
create a queue
enter cloud platform
dot ui
sign up
then
go to the orchestrator
the tenant which you have created
select the folder context
go to the folder context and you can see
cues here
go to the queues
and you can see a option to add here
click on add
and enter a queue name
[Music]
i'll enter it as ref
enter any description if you want
give
unique reference yes
and act
and you can see a queue has been added
so you can add an asset as well to add
an asset you can go to add
click here add and enter the asset name
[Music]
and select the type
whatever is required say boolean
and by default be it as false and create
so this is how you create an asset
so let's go to the ui path studio so
what we are basically doing is we are
building two process one to feed a queue
in the orchestrator that is a dispatcher
process and one to process transaction
from the queue
that is using the robotic enterprise
framework
so in dispatcher process what we do is
we get entries from an excel file and
add them as a queue items in the
orchestrator
we have already created a queue
we started project as sequence and added
a try cat we started with the sequence
added a try catch activity in the try
block
we used a retransactivity to read first
10 lines
from a1 to c11 from an excel file and
store them in a newly created data
table variable
we used for each row to loop through the
rows of the data table variable and add
each of them in a queue using the add
queue item activity
then we use the log message
we use log message activity to lock the
fact that the dispatching process was
successful
that is how we created the dispatcher
process
we will create a
performer
using robotic enterprise framework what
it does is we get titles from the queue
and processes
so
[Music]
in the dispatcher process
let's go to the initialization state
first
so we'll understand initialization state
in detail so the entire index block is
kept inside the try catch
if you go to the documents here
and if you go to the data folder you can
see a config file here
so config file this is the file we use
in the init state it has three sheets
settings constants and assets
you can give any values whatever you
want for maximum retry number the value
should be zero
when you are working with your
orchestrator queues the value should be
zero
so this config file is stored in the
data folder
and it has three sheets settings
constants and assets
this is the queue name process abc
let's get back to the
framework
so we are initializing system error if
the error is nothing it will go to the
next state
if first run read local configuration
file
you can see by default there are many
variables created
you should know them and utilize them
whenever required
the config variable
the value type is dictionary type config
is nothing
if you go here
you can see a config is nothing
initially there is no value so initially
config is nothing then it will input
init all settings workflow
let's open this first run
so it will invoke init all settings
workflow to see this workflow click on
open workflow
it has three arguments
it has three arguments in config file in
config sheets and out config
this is of type string type string and
out config is of type distance
and direction this is a both our input
and this is out
let's open the workflow and understand
so basically what this workflow does is
this workflow outputs setting dictionary
with the key value pairs to be used in
the project
settings are referred from the local
config file and then fetched from the
orchestrator assets assets will
overwrite the config file settings
putting in it all settings workflow
invoked to initialize all settings and
data for application and process used
in this part the setting constant and
assets in the config file from the data
folder are read in the initialize all
settings
so
let's go back
the orchestrator queue name
from the from the configuration file in
the argument case is specified and it
provides a backward compatibility
next we have invoked process
if we go to the arguments here
we can see the
orchestrator queue name you can assign a
queue name here if you have created a
queue
so info kill process
next we have invoke kill process it is a
logging activity called killing process
depending on the project you can add
active it is a logging activity called
killing process depending on the project
you can add activities
and add log fields in ad lock fields if
you want to add any details in the log
file then you can do it using all log
fields init all applications
workflow in this workflow invoke to open
apps and check the status credentials
and so on
and that there are two transitions in
this when it is successful it gets
transition to get transaction data when
there is a system exception it goes to
the end process
so
so in short what initialization state
does is at the end of this workflow that
is the initialization state it reads the
config file and stores the key and value
inside the dictionary that is the out
config out config dictionary variable
has all config excel file data
let's see the get transaction data
when you are in the orchestrator and you
want to immediately stop a job from for
some reason when the job is stopped this
activity gets
activated there is a variable created
should stop
if it's a boolean variable by default
it's false when it gets activated the
value becomes yes then it will go to the
log stop message as stop process
requested
and it will end the process when
the transaction item is nothing
else it will go to the try get
transaction data
here it has seven arguments
and let's see the workflow invoke get
transaction data workflow
click on open workflow
it gets the data from the spreadsheets
databases email web api or ui path
server use if no new data items then set
out the transaction item to nothing
if a new transaction item is retrieved
then it gets the additional information
about it it gives the condition where
our transaction item is not nothing then
it will add the transaction information
to the log fields
it is about the get transaction data
workflow the process transaction state
the process is a sequence with a try
catch activity set to catch both system
exceptions and business exceptions
inside the try block the process
transaction workflow invoke that has
simple process like to attach the ui
demo application and three type into
activities to fill in and click accept
button
and if you see look at the transitions
it has three transition system exception
whose destination is the initialization
state business exception goes back to
the get transaction data and success it
goes to the get transaction data finally
the end process state where the
applications is closed
what is excel automation
excel automation is a task automation
involving excel files studio x enables
the creation of automation project
involving various types of data from an
excel file using various specialized
activities
to create an excel automation we must
use excel file resource when creating a
new project that includes excel an excel
file must be specified within it so that
all of the subsequent actions can access
the data contained within that file
why use an excel automation
uipath allows you to automate excel in
various ways such as excel application
scope activities and workbook activities
excel automation simplifies your
application by performing tasks such as
formatting cells updating values and
running macros automatically
excel task in automated process can also
be integrated with several other
functions across the enterprise using an
rpa solution
the benefit of excel automation in
general is that it can save people many
are spent manually completing tasks
advantages of excel
automation productivity excel automation
provides higher production rates and
increased productivity
efficiency some of the functions of
excel can easily create automated tasks
and custom logic with functions like
macros macros are an excellent way to
save time on predictable repetitive
tasks hence excel automation is
efficient
better product quality
excel automation improves quality in
several ways including eliminating human
error increasing consistency and
accuracy the ability to create more
complex projects and the detection of
mistakes along the way
improved safety excel allows you to
protect your work whether it's to
prevent someone from opening a workbook
without a password to grant read-only
access to a workbook or to symbolize
your worksheet so you don't delete any
data
reduced labor because automation will
perform all the repetitive tasks more
accurately and productively than humans
thus reduces labor
reduced lead time a lead time is the
amount of time that elapses between the
start and finish of a process excel
automation reduces the lead time
let's look how to install an excel
package
let's jump into the uipath studio to
install an excel package go to the
manage packages
you can see the packages that are
installed go to all packages
and search for uipath excel activities
by default an updated version will be
installed if the excel package is not
installed you can install it from here
so in my device this activity is already
installed
this is the place from where you can
install any activities or any packages
let's see some of the commonly used
excel activities
these are some of the commonly used
excel activities redrain select range
save workbook autofill range copy paste
range insert and delete columns so
insert inserting a column at the
specified location in a sheet or a table
or a range
and to delete a column you can delete it
from a specified range or the table
there are filters
filter table so what filters does is you
can use the filter action to create a
filter in a range table or a sheet based
on the values in a single column we also
have vlookup vlookup which stands for
vertical lookup is an excel feature that
when enabled searches and retrieves data
from a specified column we will explore
all of these activities in the demo
section in detail
let's look at the demo in this demo we
have an excel sheet that has a record of
covet cases in five states of india in
2021
so we will create an excel automation to
represent the number of cases in charge
it's easy to understand looking at the
charts rather than looking at the huge
numbers
then we will upload the file on the
drive
so let's jump into the ui path studio
and get started
this is the excel file which i have
created
it has all the number of cases in this
five states in the year 2021 in the
month of jan feb march and april
all this record i have taken it from a
website called prsindia dot org
so i have two sheets sheet one and sheet
two
so let's jump into the ui path studio
to start off with the demo we need to
have the three packages installed
one is the ui path excel activities
package
the other one is uipath g suite dot
activities this activity this package is
used for
drive top load on the drive
then
the other package is
balareva excel activities
this package is used for bar graph and
pie chart
so
after installing this three packages
we'll get started
so let's create a new sequence
name it as sequence
to
so first we'll drag and drop an excel
application scope
so excel application scope what it does
is it opens an excel workbook and sets
the scope for excel activities
when this activity is completed the
specified workbook and the excel
application are closed when the workbook
application variable is specified in the
output workbook activities field the
spreadsheet is not closed
after this drag and drop
create table activity
so by default we have sheet1
and
enter the range
so the range is in this excel sheet
the range is from a1 to
f5 so enter the range
for this
we need to enter the file path
so we'll select the file
so we have selected the file
we have entered the
enter the table name
say
number of cases
[Music]
so once this much is done
next we'll drag and drop a bar chart
drop it outside the excel application
scope
and select the file path
so select the file
so select the file
select this cell range
that is the same range
what we had entered earlier
a1
to s5
so once that is done if the chart title
say basis
and you can select the chart type bar
stack 3d clustered 3d stand whatever is
required
for now we will select bar cluster
we have many other options to explore
data label type
will keep it in
show value so that it shows the value
and
select
show value
if you want show percentage you can
select percentage
and select show legend
and size
you can vary the size accordingly how
much ever you want
so i'll keep the size as
350
to 350.
you can change the width
[Music]
so the bar chart is done
and you can enter the sheet which sheet
are you using so it's sheet one
so we will drag and drop pie chart
select the file
similarly enter the options here
enter the cell range the same range
a1 is to f5
show percent will show value
show legend
select show value
and select the sheet which you are we
will select the sheet too
so done
so we have completed till here
next we need to upload this on the
google drive so
we'll select this option upload file
select the file
we have selected the file
so select the destination folder
for that
go to your google drive account
so we will go there
so in my drive i have created a folder
called excel automation
so i'll copy this url
till here not the entire
copy this
and
go to your ui patch studio
and paste it in the destination folder
give your double quotes
then create a variable and
create a variable as file
oops there is an error
we have forgotten to use a g-suite
application
this can be only used inside our g-suite
application
so drag and drop a g-suite application
and inside g-suite application
will write this so
there is god
so we'll run the file now
we'll save it
and
run
you can see the file is getting
run
so the execution is ended
we will navigate
to the drive
so here you can see
the file is successfully uploaded will
open the file
it's working on the graph
here you go here you can see the bar
graph
for the sheet one
with the values
number of values and each state wise
and for sheet 2
we created a pie chart so here we go
here you can see the
what is web automation
the concept of allowing software robots
to do predefined actions activities and
procedures on a web browser or an online
application is known as web automation
web automation can help with the
operations like form filling screen
scraping data extraction and transfer
across apps websites and testing and
periodic report preparation
features of web automation in uipath
uipath is compatible with all webs
it is compatible with html ajax java
silverlight and pdf
automated data entry data entry from an
excel spreadsheet to website can be
automated in ui path
it provides simple web testing without
any programming knowledge uipath helps
in designing a valid test
no coding is required we can create
automation with a simple to use
graphical workflow designer
playback precision ui path provides 100
playback precision web automation can be
done regardless of the browser version
screen position or size
how does web automation work in ui path
a built-in recorder in uipath web
automation can read and implement
web-based activities
it uses attributes to identify web items
and manipulates them accurately while
keeping up with page changes
it can be used with any website no
matter how sophisticated and can be
installed remotely through the network
the graphical workflow editor is simple
to use and does not require any coding
knowledge it's something that any user
with no programming experience can do
you save time and money by automating
web-based workflows with ui path
let's look at the demo
so in this demo we will scrape data from
the simply learns website we'll go to
simplylands website
so consider a scenario where a customer
wants to know details about a particular
course
suppose if i want to know all the ui
path related resources that are present
on the website so i'll search as ui path
and i'll select all free resources that
are available on the website
so here you can see there are 27 results
27 free resources available on the
simply lens website
so i'll scrape all of this data so using
data scraping option in ui path i'll
scrape the resource name
along with the type whether it's an
article or video tutorial and along with
that i'll scrape the url so i'll scrape
all these three things and copy it in
the excel sheet and the excel sheet over
and mail i'll send it to the customer
so let's get started so let's jump into
ui path studio and get started with the
demo so let's create a new flowchart
we'll name the flowchart as
web automation
since we are
showing this demo under web automation
so a new flowchart is created so in this
flowchart we will
drag and drop a sequence activity
right click
right click and select as set as start
node
so open the sequence
and drag and drop and open browser
activity
in the open browser activity select the
browser type
select the whichever browser you want
i'll select chrome
and
one more thing you need to do is
go to home go to tools and
install the ui path extensions click on
chrome
and if you want to continue installing
uipath extension for chrome please close
all your chrome process then click on ok
so then click on ok and your ui path
extension
for chrome will get installed
so since i have already installed i'll
click on cancel
when after installing when you open
chrome so your screen will look like
this so where you have to enable the
extension click on enabling extension
and the chrome extension will be
installed in your
device
okay so let's
come back to
uipath studio so select the open browser
select the browser where you want to get
it installed so let's create a
variable here
let's create a variable as website url
let's go to variable and enter the url
so let's go to the
simply lunch website
and copy the url
once the url is copied so this open
browser activity is a container that
enables you to open a browser at a
specified url and execute multiple
activities within it
so we have selected the open browser so
inside the open browser activity we will
drag and drop maximize window activity
maximize window it maximizes the
indicated window
so after this next we need to drag and
drop type into activity
so we'll drag and drop
type into activity
bring it outside
bring it outside the open browser
indicate on the screen the first thing
is we need to select the search bar
so we'll select the search bar
and what we are entering here is ui
paths since we are searching for ui path
course
so enter ui path
and after entering ui path we need to
click on enter
so we need to enter to search the uipath
related resources so click on this plus
button and
select the enter option
select enter
so
separate this concatenate it
okay so this is done
so once in the browser after entering ui
part
the next thing we need to do is
click on this free resources click on
this all option check this box
so for that what we have to do
is
search for click
option click activity
and select this click activity
indicate on screen
and select this click
so this is done next thing what we need
to do is when we click here on all we
find 27 results
so when we do it automatically when the
bot does is
when the robot does this thing it does
not go down and refresh all the results
what it does is
when it opens this page without loading
the below results how much our results
are available some 10 results it will
copy only those 10 results it will not
refresh and copy the results which are
below
so for that what we have to do is
we will go to your patch studio we will
select drag and drop one more type into
activity
and will indicate on screen
we'll scroll down
till the bottom
and we'll simply select this
blank
screen
just because
so that the every time the robot comes
into this page it goes till the bottom
and copies all the results that is why
we select simply a blank screen here and
it is showing an error we have to enter
something here so we'll select a command
say
since we are scrolling it down we'll
select down and this much is done
so go back to the flowchart
which we had created automation
and we'll drag and drop a new sequence
so till here it's done
where we are opening the simplylearns
website and searching for path
next we what we'll do is we will
scrape the data
so we'll rename it as data scraping
we'll open the sequence so data scraping
is something where we extract structured
data from a browser application or a
document to a data table
so we'll click on data scraping
so we'll open the browser so we have
opened the browser now we'll select the
data which we want to extract so click
on next
scroll up
so first we'll select the resource name
so we'll select top ui path interview
questions to create a pattern we need to
indicate a similar field preferably the
last in the collection or the second one
so what we'll do is we'll select the
second one
and we can create a column and we'll
name the column as
resources
if you want you can take the url
we'll take the url before that
we'll take the type so
these are the resources
for 27 resources
if the maximum number of results it will
go to is 100 if we enter 100 year if you
want more than 100 you can remove this
100 and keep it as 0 so it will select
all
0 for all
so after this will extract correlated
data
this time we will extract the type
whether it's an article or it's the
video tutorial
click on article
and indicate the similar field for the
next one we'll select video tutorial
so this column will name it as type
and will extract the url of each
resource
and we will name the column as say
links
okay next
and we are done so enter on finish
this data spanning multiple pages in our
case there is no multiple pages there is
only one page
in case if there are multiple pages
you can click on yes here press s to
indicate it scroll down and select the
next pages
but since in this page there is only one
page so we'll click on no
okay this much is done we have scraped
data so after the data scraping is done
we want to copy this scrape data into an
excel sheet so to copy it in the excel
sheet we need excel application scope
so we'll search for excel application
scope activity
so excel application scope activity
opens an excel workbook providing a
scope for excel activities when this
activity ends the workbook and excel
applications are closed if the specified
file does not exist a new excel file is
created so for this
excel application scope so we'll go to
desktop go to new and create a new
microsoft excel worksheet
we'll name it as
ui path
new ipad details
so we have created a file
we will go back to the ui patch studio
now we'll select the file which we had
created
we'll go to desktop and select the file
uipath details and we'll click on open
next we'll drag and drop right range
activity
we'll search for
right range activity
bring it inside the do
and by default it is sheet1 and a1
so right range activity writes the data
from a data table in a spreadsheet
starting from the cell
if the starting cell isn't specified the
writing begins at a1 cell
so once that is done
now we need to enter the variable that
is extract data table variable which we
extracted here that is this variable
extract data table
we need to enter this variable
go here and
search for
extract data table variable so this much
is done we have script data from the
simply learns website then using the
pixel application scope we have written
the data in the excel sheet
so let's run till here and see whether
it's scraping the data and writing in
the excel sheet
so we'll save it and click on run so
let's see
we'll close this
here you can see it's opening the simply
lens website
entering ui path
oops we have made an error okay let's go
and let's stop here
so we had made an error here the bracket
was missing it is y now we have
corrected it let's save and run
for that close this
it's opening the simply launch website
it will enter ui path
select all the free resources
then it will copy this in the excel
sheet
you can see it's copying
so let's open the excel worksheet which
we created and let's check
if it has copied so you can see in the
excel file which we had created
the data has been scraped and copied
here
the first column it is the
course name or the resource name which
we had copied in the second column it is
the type whether it is an article or
video tutorial in the third column it is
the url
there are no headers here right we can
give the headers so we'll go to the ui
path studio
and if you click on excel application
scope or write range
here you can see add headers
so click here and the headers will be
added in the excel sheet
so this much is done
now next step is we need to send this
excel file over and mail
so to send this excel file over and mail
let's go to activities let's drag and
drop a new sequence
we'll use a separate sequence to send
the activities over our mail
sorry not here
we'll connect this
will name this activity as
main since we are sending it over mail
open this sequence
the first activity we need here is get
password activity
so search for get password
drag and drop it get password activity
encrypts a password by associating it
with the current user
only workflows running under the current
user context can decrypt the password so
go to the password and enter your email
id password
and in the result create a new variable
and store the password in a variable so
that your password is encrypted and name
the variable as
pass
word short form something password
and next activity we need is send smtp
mail message
so double click on send smtp mail
message
so this activity basically sends an
email message by using the smtp protocol
so go to the port and enter the port
which is 587
and go to the server and enter the
server
smtp
and enter the email id to which you want
to
send the mail
enter the password
the password variable which we had
created enter that
and
enter the email id here as well
so enter the subject
of the mail what you what you want the
subject to be
so i'll name it as course details
and enter the body
so i'll enter a simple hello
hello
here are the details
okay
so there is a prerequisite for this
uh you have to to receive for to send an
email you have to go to your google
account that is the email account
security option and there you have to
turn on
secured access go to the option call
secured access and turn it on
okay next we need to attach the file the
file which we want to send it over and
mail
attach the file in which we had scraped
the data from the simply learns website
so let's go to web automation the
previous sequence and copy the file path
from the excel application scroll
so we'll copy this file path
and
go back
in the attach file
we will
paste this
path
remove one double quote
click on ok
next we'll drag and drop a message box
just for like our reference to show a
message so that the process is completed
so we'll enter a simple message in the
message box like the course details have
been made successfully
so
let me correct the spelling
details okay
so now there are no errors so now the
project is complete
so what i have done is
i have taken a flowchart in the
flowchart i have taken a first sequence
in this sequence i am opening the
browser the simply learns browser i'm
maximizing it then i am
not type using the type into activity i
am recording the search bar in the
search bar i am entering the ui path and
clicking on enter so after clicking on
enter i'll select the all option where
i'll select all the resources
in the first sequence
then in the second sequence i'm scraping
the data
in scraping data option i'll scrape the
data i'll scrape the course name the
type and the url then in the excel
application scope i'll copy all the
script data in an excel file so i'll use
an excel application scope i have
created a file so in that file i'll
write the script data
in the second sequence
then finally in the third sequence i am
using the get password activity and send
smtp mail message and i am sending it
over
an email i am sending the excel file as
an attachment with an email to the
customer
this message box
simply indicates that the
mail has been successfully
sent
okay
now let me save and
click on run
so i'll close the previous browser
let me save and click on run
web automation execution is started it
is going to the browser
going to simply learn website
search for ui path click on all
resources
and it's copying the resources in an
excel sheet
after copying the resource in an excel
sheet it is sending over an email so it
has sent over an email and the message
has been displayed the course details
have been successfully made
let me go to my email inbox and check
whether i have received it
so let me click on course it has been
made successfully let me refresh
and here you can see i have received the
mail let me open this file
so here you can see i have received the
file which consists of resources the
type and the link
i hope you have understood the simple
example on web automation uipath assists
business in successfully automating
their business process
if you are planning to attend an
interview for an rpa or ui part
developer role here is a comprehensive
list of most frequently asked ui path
interview questions with answers
what is ui path
this question looks simple but people
most of the time end up giving wrong
definition
uipath is a robotic process automation
tool for large-scale end-to-end
automation
for an accelerated business change it
provides solution for business to
automate routine office activities
it uses a variety of methods to
transform tedious tasks into automated
process
what are the different components in ui
ui path consists of three components
mainly uipath studio ui path studio is a
user friendly interface that allows
users to visually plan and design
various automation process through
diagrams using the drag and drop
functionality
these diagrams are merely a structural
reflection of specific tasks that must
be completed
uipath robot after you have built your
process the next move is to put into
action in the ui path studio
uipath robots are used to translate the
strategies into tasks which are then
executed
these robots are used to assign various
tasks and carry them out in the same
manner as humans but without human
interference
when given an operation occurs on the
computer they program uipath robots to
begin executing task automatically
uipath orchestrator the orchestrator is
a web-based application in ui path
it has features for deploying monitoring
scheduling and controlling automated
bots and process it's a centralized
forum for managing and maintaining all
software bots
what are the different workflows in
uipath
sequences
a sequence is a small type of project
that is best suited for linear process
it enables developers to transition from
one activity to another easily
they can be reused numerous times
flowchart
it can be used for large or small
projects that help in development of
complex business and connecting
activities in a variety of ways
flowcharts assist in the presentation of
multiple branches of logical operators
state machine
a state machine is a machine that uses a
certain number of states for automation
during execution
it will only change states if an action
is performed on it let's look at the
next question
what is a uipath robot
the robot is a ui path execution agent
allowing you to run process created in
the studio
in order to execute process robots must
be connected to the orchestrator or
licensed locally
what are the different components of
uipath robot
service the robot service is the primary
controller for all operations
it communicates with studio the robot
agent and the robot command line
interface by an inter process
communication channel to receive and
process information
executor the robot executor is the
component that is directly responsible
for process execution
the robot service creates a robot
executor instance every time a job is
started
command line interface
the robot command line interface is a
console application that starts jobs and
waits for the results
uipath assistant is a tool designed
specifically to improve the user's
interaction with our robots from the
comfort of the desktop it is where users
can easily access manage and run
automation with a few clicks
what is the difference between attended
and unattended robot
attended robots are supervised robots
that humans operate
they work on the same workstation as a
human user and is triggered by user
events
unattended robots
unattended robots are those that do not
require human supervision to perform
tasks they run in virtual environments
without human control and can automate
any number of process
what are the features of ui path
drag and drop workflow the uipath user
will develop visual process steps by
dragging and dropping related tasks onto
the graphical workspace then with the
user interface properties they can
transform these process steps into a
visual workflow users may also use the
recorder wizard in the uipath tool to
build web-based or application workflow
record and playback the user can use
this function to record actions and
transform them into an automated process
series
inbuilt activities in uipath uipath
comes with over 300 built-in activities
covering a wide range of process
automation and application integrated
design tasks
you can find these activities in
activities pane which covers most design
tasks such as data extraction data entry
and automation
advanced scraping options scraping data
from web pages and applications is more
accessible with ui path screen scraping
furthermore the data scraping wizard
helps in the scraping of data with a
repetitive structure
scraping solution works flawlessly with
any program including dotnet java flash
pdf legacy and sap
high security and robustness you can
create super smart durable robots with
ui path visual canvas everyone in the
company can use these boards uipath
offers high security auto login
functionality to run the bots and
operates with a locked screen allowing
automated process to run in complete
privacy
what are the different recording options
in uipath
basic recording it focuses on automating
single task and is commonly used to
develop each activity's complete
selector
desktop recording it can be used for a
variety of actions as well as
application development
web recording web recording is a
standard tool for viewing and recording
web activities
citrix recording it is very widely used
for recording stuff like pictures and
virtualized environment automation
what is a manage package in uipath
the package manager functionality allows
to download activities packages
libraries frameworks wrappers and others
and view and update the ones already
installed for the project and add and
remove it
it displays the list of available
packages per feed and a list of
dependencies for the current project
the manage package windows always opens
with the project dependencies list
how to publish a project in uipath
to publish a project in uipath first
create a new project
then in the design ribbon tab click
publish the publish window will open
in the package properties tab enter the
name for package then click next
in the publish options tab select the
location where you want to publish your
project and finally the information
dialog box displays
so let's see a demo
how is it done
so let's jump in the ui patch studio
so here we are in uipath studio
let's open a workflow
i'll drag and drop a simple message box
just to show
enter a message say
hey
so i have created a simple workflow just
to show you how to publish project in
uipath
so here you can see the publish option
once you have created the project go to
the ribbon tab and click on the publish
when you click the publish window opens
here you can change the package name if
you want you can see the version new
version package icon
and release notes
so let's click on next
here you will get the custom url
where you want to publish to
then click on publish
here you go you can see publishing
package
so a info dialog box appears
project published successfully
if you want you can copy to the
clipboard
so this is how the project is published
in the ui path
what is data scraping and screen
scraping
data scripting is the process of
extracting structured data from a
browser application or document and
saving it to a database or a dot csv
file or even an excel spreadsheet
screen scraping methods are activities
that allow data to be extracted from a
specific ui element or document such as
a dot pdf file
explain the different types of
automation in uipath
excel automation excel automation is a
useful tool for sorting deleting
retrieving and analyzing data
it is simple to migrate and integrate
data into platforms
studio x has a strong integration with
microsoft excel and ships with several
activities that automate excel task
mail automation enables task automation
with emails from the outlook desktop
application gmail and outlook 365.
add the activities that use data from
the account inside the resource activity
after adding the account to the
automation as a resource using a used
outlook 365 use gmail or use desktop
outlook app activity
word automation in the word automation
add the word document to be worked on by
using a word file activity and then add
the word activities to automate within
the use word file
powerpoint automation
powerpoint automation allows the user to
automate the most common task in
powerpoint presentation at the
presentation to work with the use
powerpoint presentation activity and
then inside the use powerpoint
presentation add the presentation
activities to automate
file automation
it refers to the automation of tasks
performed on your computer with files
and folders such as creating copying or
renaming files and folders
studio x includes several activities
that automate tasks that you perform
with files and folders
csv automation
in csv automation add the csv activities
inside the use excel file activity where
the excel file is defined to move data
between csv and excel
explain a few read and write activities
read range read range reads the values
of an excel range and stores in a data
table variable
read cell reads the values of an excel
cell and stores in a variable
read csv reads all entries from a
specified csv file
write range writes data from a data
table variable to a spreadsheet
write cell writes a value or formula
into a specified spreadsheet cell
write csv overwrites a specified data
table to a csv file
what is an excel application scope
excel application scope opens an excel
workbook and sets the scope for excel
activities
when this activity is completed the
specified workbook and excel application
are closed
what is an orchestrator
uipath orchestrator is a web application
that orchestrates the execution of
repetitive process
it manages the creation monitoring
scheduling and controlling of bots and
process
it can manage the entire robot fleet
name some orchestrator capabilities
provisioning
provisioning establishes and maintains
the connection between the robots and
the web application
deployment ensures that it delivers the
correct package versions to the assigned
robots for execution
configuration looks after the
maintenance and delivery of robot
environments and process configuration
queues
queues ensures that it automatically
distributes the workload across robots
monitoring manages user permissions and
keeps track of robot recognition details
logging
logs are stored and indexed in an sql
database
explain process job asset and queue
the process page allows you to build new
process from uploaded packages managing
existing process and keep all of your
process up to date with the latest
package version
jobs
on an uipath robot a job represents the
execution of procedure it can start the
execution of job in either attended or
unattended mode
queues a queue is a storage container
that can accommodate an infinite number
of objects multiple types of data such
as invoice information or customer data
are stored in queue objects
other systems such as sap or salesforce
are used to process this data
assets assets are usually shared
variables or credentials that can be
used through several automation projects
they allow you to store unique
information that the robots can easily
access
how to connect a robot to the
orchestrator
step 1 open uipath assistant
step 2 sign in the uipath orchestrator
step 3 create a tenant
step 4 connect the robot to the
orchestrator and step 5
check the status
it shows connected and licensed
so let's see a demo of how to do this
so let's jump into the uipath studio
open new step 1 open ui path assistant
so will open ui path assistant
after opening uipath assistant
login to the uipath orchestrator
so go to the browser
go to the browser and type
platform.uipart.com
this will take to the uipath website
so sign in
if you're new to this if you don't have
the account
then you can enter all the details and
login
since i have already created an account
i'll sign in
after logging in the uipath orchestrator
go to the admin
here you can create a new tenant
you can add a tenant here and create a
new tenant since i have already created
a tenant named admin
so after creating a tenant connect the
robot to the orchestrator
go to the uipath assistant
go to preferences
go to preferences
go to orchestrator settings
here you can see the status it is
offline
click on the sign in button
once you click on the sign in button
allow this open ui path
here you can see it is connecting
and you can see it is connected and
licensed
so the ui path robot is now connected
with the orchestrator
what is a tenant context and folder
context
in current context to view and control
tenant level entities in the
orchestrator pick tenant from the
sidebar menu with only one instance of
the orchestrator multi-tenancy allows
isolating data
for the folder context from this sidebar
menu pick any available folder to view
and control the entities within the data
folder
so i'll show you let's
go to the orchestrator
so
let's go to the orchestrator
here you can see this is the tenant
context
to view and control the tenant level
entities in orchestrator you can pick
the tenant from the sidebar menu
from the sidebar menu pick any available
folder so these are the folders pick any
available folder to view and control the
entities within that folder so this is
with respect to the folder context
what is an re framework
the robotic enterprise framework is a
state machine based project template
it allows to handle even the most
complex business situations
it's designed to incorporate all of the
industry's best practices for logging
exception management application
initialization and other areas
what are the features of re framework
settings
during the initialization phase of
several process some configuration
settings and configuration values are
frequently read
like urls to a web application
orchestrator queue names and default
logging messages
logging
the built-in locking mechanism is
another helpful feature of the framework
the majority of the system's workflows
use log message activities to output
information about what is happening at
each execution stage
business exception
if the issue is with the data or any
underlying business requirement the
system skips the transaction and moves
on to the next search exceptions are
known as business exceptions
application exception if the issue can
be resolved by restarting applications
the framework will do so automatically
and attempt to process the transaction
again
search exceptions are known as
application exceptions
how to merge two excel files into a
single excel file
first we need to create a
sequence after creating a sequence we
need a few activities like read csv
activity assign activity data table
activity and write cs file activity so
we'll drag and drop all these activities
and do the process
then we'll run the sequence and see the
output
so let's jump into the ui path studio
and start with the
workflow
so we are in the ui path studio
i have already created a sequence you
can go to new and create a sequence or
press ctrl n
so after starting a sequence first we
will drag and drop
read csv activity
since we are using two excel files
so we need to read csv activity we will
drag and drop another read csv activity
so we will select the location of the
first excel file
select the first excel file
i'll show you
both the excel files which we are
merging
so this is the first excel file
so it has five rows
five names
so we'll this is the first excel file
and
this is the second excel files
this excel file has five different names
and the other excel file has five
different rows
so these are the two excel files will
merge both these excel files into a
single new excel file
so we'll close this excel files
so in the first read csv activity
we have copied the location of the first
excel file in the output 2
we will select this
and create a variable right click and
create a variable and let's say name the
variable as sl underscore five one
we have named a variable
okay now we'll
go to another read csv file and select
the location of the second file
so i have downloaded this sample excel
files from the internet
just for the demo
right click and create a variable
let's say name this variable as sl
underscore file two
so now that we have dragged and drop to
read csv activities now next we need
assign activity
so drag and drop and assign activity
so assign activity has two parameters as
you can see two and enter a vb
expression
in the two parameter in this right click
and create a variable
and name the variable
let's say
merged
essay
after naming the variable enter an
expression here
so enter the expression as
sl underscore
file1 which is the variable for file1
select this
and enter the expression.clone
what this clone function does is the
clone function creates a new data table
with the same structure
but does not copy the data so we are
creating a new excel file that is the
third file in which we are merging the
data tables of both the excel file so
the third excel file which we are
creating will have the same structure as
the file one so this clone function
creates a third excel file with the same
structure as the file one
so it's showing an error so select this
assign
let's go to variables
here you can see variable type string
change it to system dot data dot data
table
and here you go the error is gone
okay
so now we have dragged and dropped
assign activity
the next activity which we need
is merge data table activity
let's search for merge
data table activity
drag and drop
modulatable activity
we need two merge data table activity
since we have two excel files
select the first merge data table
activity go to the destination
and enter the destination which is the
variable which we created in the assign
activity the merged set
so
enter this
and enter the source file
that is the variable which you created
in file one
that is sl underscore
file one
similarly similarly
go to merge data table
and
enter the same destination
but here the source will be the second
file
okay
now that we have dragged and dropped too
much data tables the next activity we
need is a write csv file
so we'll search for write csv file
after dragging and dropping write csv
activity
go to file path
and create a
file create a file say
one will name it as
file
3
save the file
now that we have created the file
we'll write from the data table that is
we need to copy the merge data tab
so we'll enter
now that we have finished the program
the file is created let's save
and run it
process execution has started and ended
so
let's go to the file
so this is the file which we created
let's open this file
and here you can see
both the excel files have been merged
into a single excel file
let's go to the next question how to
send a file over and mail
so first create a sequence and create a
file after you have created a file drag
and drop get password activity
then drag and drop a smtp mail message
activity
so basically these two activities are
used to send a file over me
then run the sequence
so we'll jump into the ui path studio
and see
so this was the previous question which
we answered how to merge two excel files
so the same file we will send it over
and mail
so we need a get password activity
so we'll drag and drop a get password
activity
so if you go to the properties section
enter the password to whichever
mail you are sending this file enter the
password of that mail id
[Music]
after entering the password in the
result go and create a variable
so that password is stored in that
variable so
name the variable say anything randomly
so i have named the variable
after
after this you need a smtp mail message
activity
so drag and drop send smtp mail message
in smtp mail message
under the properties pane under the host
enter the port value
for the port number which is
587
sorry
after entering the port number go to the
server
and enter it as smtp.gmail.com
okay
now after entering the email id
go to your email and enter your email id
to which you want to send this file
don't forget to use double quotes
otherwise it will show an error
enter the password
so we had showed the password in the
variable say sss
so
we'll write that
so after that
enter the email id here under the to
option
and enter the subject
say it has demo since we are showing a
demo
we will enter the subject as demo this
is the this subject and body
is the subject and body of the mail
now let's attach the file which we have
created
[Music]
copy the file location
so we'll go to the file
and copy this file location
after attaching the file
let's save
and run
the process has started
and the process has ended
here you can see in the output
the process has started and the process
has ended let's go over the main and
check if we have received
here we go we have received the file
let's open the file
and here you go the same this is the
same file which had merged the data
so the file has been sent over the mail
one thing you have to keep in mind
when you use the get password activity
go to your google account in the
security section
go to this secure app access and turn it
on
you have to turn it on to receive the
file over and mail
explain the different states and
transitions in re framework
there are four key states in re
framework
the first state is initial state this is
the point at which the procedure begins
it's an event where the process
initializes the settings and runs
application test to ensure that all of
the prerequisites for the process start
are met
next we have get transaction state
this state retrieves the next
transaction object this can be a queue
item or a collection item transaction
items are queue items by default but
this can be modified to meet your needs
this is also when the developer can set
the condition to exit the state when
there are no items to process
process transaction state
for the transaction item obtained in
previous step it performs actions logic
in various application
if a transaction item has been processed
the process moves on to the next
transaction item available
end process date
the procedure is completed and the
applications open during automations are
closed in the end process state
let's jump into the ui path studio and
see the different transitions in robotic
enterprise framework
so this is the robotic enterprise
framework this is the
initialization state the first state so
it has two transitions
system error that is system exception
and successful
when it shows system exception when a
system error is not nothing it gets
transition to the end process suppose if
you have an application exception during
the initialization phase and we don't
have enough details to start a process
then as a result we are going to end
process state to wrap it up
and the successful is when a system
error is nothing it gets transitioned to
get transaction state
and during initialization we have no
error system exception
it gets transitioned to the transaction
data suppose if you have a
transaction during the initialization no
data and we don't have any answers to
start approaching no data is when the
transaction is nothing processing we are
at the end of our data collection so it
goes to the successful is when and in
the transactions
is
you can create and modify google
calendar events manage google drive
files read and send email messages and
create new google sheets and google
documents
is
and its parents in the shape of an xml
fragment the selector aids in the
automatic generation of the selection by
utilizing wildcards
what is a machine explain standard
machine and machine template
the machine page allows you to provision
and manages machines to use them to
register robots with orchestrator
it displays the types of machine that we
currently in use it enables you to
design your machine by the standard or
template
standard machine it should be used when
the name of the machine on which you
want to define robots is the same every
time you connect to it you define the
machine once and then you can connect to
as many robots as you want from the
robots page
machine template it should be used
whenever the name of the machine on
which you want to define robot changes
you represent this entity once and then
you use a unique active directory
username to connect to any number of
attended floating robots
explain delay do if and switch
activities in ui path the delay activity
allows you to pause the automation for a
specified amount of time
this activity is beneficial in projects
that require precise timing such as
waiting for a specific application to
start or for some information to be
processed before using it in the another
activity
the do activity allows you to run a
specific piece of automation while a
condition is met
the project exits the loop when the
specified condition is no longer
completed this activity can be used to
iterate through all the array elements
or execute a specific action multiple
times
if activity the if activity includes a
statement as well as two conditions
if the statement is true the first
condition is executed if the statement
is false the second condition is
executed if activities can be used to
make decision based on variable values
switch activity the switch activity
allows you to choose one of the several
options based on the value of specified
expression the switch activity uses an
integer argument by default
but you can change it in the properties
panel under the type argument list
the switch activity can be used to
categorize data based on predefined
number of cases
how to create chart in excel
step 1 create a new sequence go to the
ui path studio and create a new sequence
and then
drag and drop the following activities
to create the chart we need to use excel
application scope create table activity
and bar chart and pie chart activity
depending on which type of charts you
want to create
then at last after completing then run
the sequence
we will see a demo of this in the uipath
studio
how to upload a file on drive
so create a new sequence and drag and
drop a g-suite application
then inside g-suite application drag and
drop upload file activity fill in the
details
and finally run the suite
let's go and see a demo to how to create
charts in excel file and how to upload a
file on your drive
so let's jump into the ui patch studio
this is the excel file which i have
created
it has all the number of cases in this
five states in the year 2021 the month
of jan feb march and april all this
record i have taken it from a website
called prs india dot org
so i have two sheets sheet one and sheet
two
so let's jump into the ui path studio
to start off with the demo we need to
have the three packages installed
one is the ui path excel activities
package
the other one is uipath g suite dot
activities this activity this package is
used for
drive topload only drive
then
the other package is
balareva excel activities this package
is used for bar graph and pie chart
so
after installing these three packages
we'll get started
so let's create a new sequence
name it as sequence
2
so first we'll drag and drop an excel
application scope
so excel application scope what it does
is it opens an excel workbook and sets
the scope for excel activities
when this activity is completed the
specified workbook and excel
applications are closed when the
workbook application variable is
specified in the output workbook
activities field the spreadsheet is not
closed
after this drag and drop a create table
activity
so by default we have sheet1 and
enter the range
so the range is in this excel sheet the
range is from a1 to f5
so enter the range
for this
we need to enter the file path so we'll
select the file
so we have selected the file
we have entered the
enter the table name
say
number of cases
so once this much is done
next we'll drag and drop a bar chart
drop it outside the excel application
scope
and select the file path
so select the file
so select the file
select this cell range
that is the same range what we had
entered earlier
a1
to s5
so once that is done if the chart title
say basis
and you can select the chart type
bar stack 3d clustered 3d stand whatever
is required
for now we will select bar cluster
we have many other options to explore
data label type
will keep it in
show value so that it shows the value
and
select
show value
if you want show percentage you can
select percentage
and select show legend
and size
you can vary the size accordingly how
much ever you want
so i'll keep the size as
350.
to 350
you can change the width
so the bar chart is done
and you can enter the sheet which sheet
are you using so it's sheet1
so we will drag and drop pie chart
select the file
similarly enter the options here
enter the cell range
the same range
a1 is to f5
show percent will show value
show legend
select show value
and select the sheet which you want
we'll select the sheet too
so done
so we have completed till here
next we need to upload this on the
google drive so we'll select this option
upload file
select the file
so we have selected the file
so select the destination folder
for that
go to your google drive account
so we will go there
[Music]
so in my drive i have created a folder
called excel automation
so i'll copy this
url
till here not the entire
top to this
and
go to your ui patch studio and paste it
in the destination folder
here double quotes
then create a variable and
create a variable as file
oops there is an error
oh we have forgotten to use a g-suite
application
this can be only used inside a g-suite
application
so drag and drop a g-suite application
and inside g-suite application
will write this so there is god
so we'll run the file now
we'll save it
and
you run see the file is getting
run
so the execution is ended
we will navigate
to the drive
so here you can see
the file is successfully uploaded will
open the file
it's working on the graph
here you go here you can see the bar
graph
for the sheet one
with the values
number of values and each state wise and
for sheet
we created a pie chart so here you go
where you can see the project
robotic process automation is a software
technology that anyone can use to
automate digital tasks
automation anywhere is one of the top
rpa platform that allows business to
automate the process
prerequisite enterprise control room
requires a server level machine to be
installed the server can be a physical
machine in your data center or a cloud
platform instance
cloud platforms like amazon web services
google cloud platform and microsoft
azure
the device should have a processor of
8 core intel xeon processor
it should have storage disk space of at
least 500 gb
and network of one gigabit ethernet it
is recommended that you configure the
enterprise control room network
bandwidth to be greater than one
gigabyte ethernet because uplink traffic
can quickly exceed one gigabit ethernet
depending on the complexity of the
automation run
operating system
automation anywhere is compatible with
the operating system such as windows 10
windows server 2012 windows server 2016
and windows server 2019. automation
anywhere supports both 32-bit and 64-bit
operating system versions
finally the system should have a ram of
16 gb let's look at the features of the
community edition
students and developers can use the
automation 360 cloud platform for free
with the community edition
it is completely web-based you can build
a rpa bot in the cloud from any device
thanks to a completely web-based
experience that requires no download
utilize the cloud to gain access to
cutting edge enterprise class technology
the most recent enterprise class
technology
community edition will allow you to stay
up to date with the latest version of
our enterprise platform
ai drag and drop with direct iqbot
integration you can automate your
document centric process
drag and drop simplicity with instance
on ease of use
create bots at any skill level
create bots using no code low code or
bring your own code options
begin by using free bots use free build
bots for personal productivity business
continuity and other purposes
let's look at the installation of
community edition
let's go to the browser
go to the automation anywhere official
website automation anywhere.com
after going to the website
scroll down
here you can see community edition
click on community edition
to download the community edition free
fill out the form fill all the necessary
details and click on get free community
edition
once you fill in all the details and
click on get free community edition you
will receive an email
so you will receive an email the email
consists of a control room url a
username and password
so open this control room url
so click on the control room link a
username password a login page appears
where you need to enter the username and
password so enter the username and
password which you have received in the
mail and login
unlike other additions in community
edition there will be no client option
you can develop the bots on the cloud
let us build our first board
let us go to the control room
so we'll build our first board
so the first step under the robotic
process automation click on create a bot
so enter the name say first bot
enter the name and
click on create and edit
so you can see the first bot is
successfully created
now search for the message box here
double click on the message box to add
it in the workflow
so enter the message here enter the
message which you want to be displayed
so let us enter say
hello how are you
so we have entered this message
after entering the message click on save
button
and after saving click on run
it's downloading the dependencies
here you can see the message has been
displayed hello how are you
when when you do it for the first time
when you click on the run button a
pop-up will appear to connect to my
computer
then the file will get downloaded the
file is to install a bot agent the bot
will get connected to the control room
then there will be an option to enable
extension to the chrome
after doing all that finally
finally the bot is ready to display the
message so here you can see
the message has been displayed
what is automation anywhere
automation anywhere is a well-known
robotic process automation tool that
enables business to automate end-to-end
business operations
automation anywhere provides powerful
and user-friendly rba capabilities such
as cloud native web-based intelligent
automation solution for automating any
complex task
it is a web-based management system that
employs a control room to execute
automated tasks
it improves the efficiency of business
process and reduces the need for human
labor
features of automation anywhere
automation anywhere offers an easy to
use interface for building bots and
designing business process automation
workflows
it supports multiple operating system
such as windows linux and mac os
it consists of a recorder that works on
a variety of platforms including
microsoft windows citrix web and sap
it consists of different bot views for
collaboration
flow view for business users list view
for developers and dual view for
collaboration
automation anywhere supports platforms
like javascript python and vbscript as
well as advanced variable capabilities
another key feature is its versatile
architecture that allows for the
addition of new command packages
let's look at the automation anywhere
components
the first component is
automation anywhere robotic interface
aari
it is a user friendly interface that
allows business users to collaborate
with bots
users can initiate process automation
provide feedback to the bots in order
for process to be resumed and escalate
requests to additional users for
downstream processing
aari that is automation anywhere robotic
interface enables enterprises to unlock
previously unavailable automation
opportunities between humans and the
bots
iqbot an intelligent document processing
solution capable of reading and
processing a wide range of complex
documents and emails
iqbot intelligently captures classifies
and extracts semi-structured and
unstructured data using rpa and multiple
ai techniques
allowing document centric business
process to be automated end-to-end
bought inside
the analytics platform that delivers
real-time interactive and intelligent
insights into business process and
operational intelligence
bought insight takes the large amount of
content level and productivity data
generated by deployed bots and converts
it into insights via automatically
generated and customizable
dashboards discovery bot an intelligent
business solution for enterprise
business that enables end users to
discover automation opportunities
through process discovery
discovery board focuses on process
automation by capturing document process
identifying opportunities from
business-centric process and
pre-authorizing opportunities based on
roi and create bots automatically
discovery board collaborates with
business workers to identify automation
opportunities that can maximize the
return on your rpa investment
let's look at the architecture of
automation anywhere
automation anywhere platform is built
using a distributed architecture
the enterprise control room a web-based
platform that manages the development
and execution of digital workforce
provides centralized management
bot creators and bot runners are linked
to the enterprise control room
bot creators are software development
platforms for authorizing and
customizing automations
bot runners are runtime system deployed
on the machine that carry out the
automations
bot runners can be installed on desktops
in data centers or in the cloud
let's explore the architecture in detail
bot creators a bot is a self-contained
task that requires little to no human
intervention to complete the bot creator
is a customized development client for
automation anywhere that is used to
create bots
task editor event watcher bot player
auto login and local scheduler are all
included
the bot creator also includes the
ability to create boards from a device
utilizing the enterprise client
application
the device is registered with the
enterprise control room after the bot
creator user signs in for the first time
and the user can deploy bots on that
device
board runners
a bot runner has the ability to run bots
from a device utilizing the enterprise
client application the device is
registered with the enterprise control
room after the bot runner users log in
for the first time and the user can
deploy bots on that device
ports are run by the bot runner which is
a software machine
bot runners can run bots at scale after
they have been developed with bot create
control room
the enterprise control room serves as a
single point of management for all bots
enterprise control room is placed on a
server in the data center and configured
to work with the other data center
components a river proxy is in charge of
listening for request for remote
connections and sending them to the
appropriate specialized service
using a collection of specialized web
service the enterprise control room
manages schedules executes and
configures various bots and bot runner
capabilities
let's look at the types of bots in
automation anywhere
task bot
task bots are used for automating
repetitive tasks based on the rules
these tasks are simple to create and can
reliably complete multi-step procedures
document administration claims
management hr departments i.t and other
areas benefit from task bots they
increase protection reduce errors and
save money
metabot metabots are more advanced
version of taskbots metabots are
automation building components that help
with next generation integration
scalability
these are intended for scalable complex
process on a computer meta bots are used
to automate applications application
apis visual captures and integration
flow can all be used to develop meta
bots
iq
iqbot
are the next generation of intelligent
bots with the ability to think like
humans these bots are designed to learn
on their own and carry out tasks in
accordance with that learning
users can experience the potential of
automation with iq bots
which use advanced cognitive technology
and advanced artificial technologies
these boards have capabilities such as
self learning decision making and
subject matter expertise among others
data can be extracted from
semi-structured and unstructured data by
these bots
iq bots also learn to recognize patterns
so that the bot knows exactly what to do
the next time the pattern appears
iq bots also learn to recognize patterns
so that the bot knows exactly what to do
the next time the pattern appears with
each human confirmation it learns and
improves its ability to carry out the
act benefits of using automation
anywhere
time saving an easy to use interface
that allows users of varying skill
levels to easily use the product and
accelerate the learning process with
instant web-based deployment you can get
started with writing bots right away
business adaptability automation
anywhere provides regular updates
ensuring that you are always up to date
on any device anywhere it provides
continuity of operations with high
availability and disaster recovery
low cost of ownership there is no need
for additional infrastructure investment
it gives low cost maintenance
a unified platform for front office back
office and employee applications is
provided
let's look at the demo
so let's see a demo in this demo
we will create a bot which will
automatically
login inside the simply learn login page
so i'll show you
let's go to the browser i'll go to the
simply learns page
so
this is the simply lunch login page
so in this page the bot will
automatically enter the email address
password and it will click on the login
button and it will take you inside the
simply lens page
so we'll create a bot
so i'll show you how the bot works
so i have created it
let's see the output first and then
we'll get started with the
project
so i'll click on the run button
it will download all the dependencies
here you can see it's entering the email
address
it's entering the password and it will
click on the login button
so this is the project this is the
output
so you have seen the output so let's get
started
we'll close this go to the
go to the mail which you received from
the
automation anywhere and click on the
control room link and you will open up
here
after coming here
click on create a bot
so enter a name
let's say
we'll enter as loginbot
since we are
creating a project to login
if you want you can give the description
and next click on create and edit
there are three options here flow
list and dual
in the flow it only shows the flowchart
of what activities or actions you are
dragging and dropping it in the list it
shows the in the form of the list all
the actions and in the dual it shows the
flowchart as well as the actions what
actions it is performing
so first we need the browser option
so we'll search for the browser action
so this is the browser action
so the browser package contains actions
that enable you to download file find
broken lines
and launch a website
so this package basically supports
internet explorer microsoft edge and
google chrome browsers
so the browser package includes the
actions like close download file get
source code find broken lines go back
open run javascript
now for us to open the browser to open
the simply learns website we need the
open option so let's click on the open
double click on the open
so what open does is opens the browser
to a specific web page whichever web
webpage link we provides it opens that
browser so what we want to open do we
want to open it in the existing tab or a
new tab or a new window so in existing
tab it opens the web page in the
currently open tab
so this existing tab option is only
available in the google chrome browser
and new tab opens the web page in a new
tab like select the tab from the list of
the active tabs in the google chrome
browser or insert a new window variable
and in the new window this opens the web
page in a new window or of a specific
browser whichever browser you choose it
opens a webpage in a new window
so all these options are applicable in
the google chrome browser
so we will select the new window option
and the browser
okay you have these options
internet explorer mozilla firefox chrome
and microsoft edge so we will select
google chrome and will select the link
to open
so
we should select the link
so we'll go to the simplylands website
page
so this is the page we are logging in so
that is why we need the link of this
page so copy the link of this page
and paste the link here
and we need it in the new window
so save it
and
let's run and see if this opens in the
new window
let's click on run
okay so till now
we are going right
so we have entered the link and we have
run the bot and the bot is opening the
web page in the new window
so we'll close this
so after this we need the recorder
package
so search for the recorder package
so this is the recorder package in this
we have the capture action so the
capture action from the recorder package
is used to capture an interaction with
the user interface object such as a text
box button table menu radio button combo
box check box list view link tree and
package tab the capture action enables
you to add single interaction when
building your bot
so let's double click on capture option
so let's select dual
so that we can see what action it
triggers
so after selecting the capture option
so select the browser option browser
window then
click on this refresh windows
so it will show a list of
so it will show the list of pages that
are open in the browser
so scroll down
and we need learning on simply
so this is the web page
in which we are logging in so select the
web page
go down
and let's click on capture object click
on capture object
so first we need to fill in the email
address so you can see here it's showing
a red color box
so click on email address
so it will capture this object of email
address here you can see recording
capture finalization
so the object is
captured
scroll down
and here you can see action to take on
object what action should be taken on
the object which we have selected
source we need to
enter the text that is the email address
so select set text
and scroll down
and enter what text you want to enter
that
so i'll enter my email id
now scroll down
you can enter the time how much hour you
want
it is recommended to enter a 9 seconds
or 10 seconds but it's optional so we'll
skip it for now
you can see here it's the of the type
user login page
so
we have captured the first object that
is email address so we'll save it
and we'll run and see if it's entering
the email address
here you can see
it's open the webpage in the new window
and it has entered the email address
so let's go back to the control room
close this
your bot has run successfully
so now that we have entered the email
address we need to enter the password so
we will
use another capture
action
and this will will select the same
browser window
then we'll select the same
learning on simply learn
website
and we'll click on capture object
but now this time will capture the
object
password
select the password
object
and recording capture finalization
so now that the object is captured we
need to
select the action what action should be
performed
so we will select set text
now that we have selected text since we
are entering the password the password
should be credential
and when the password is credentialed
you can't enter the password here you
need to pick the password
you need to pick the password from the
locker room
so
now that
now that i have already created a
credential and entered in the locker
room for me it's showing here i'll show
you how to
create a credential and create a locker
room
so we'll save it till here for now we'll
save here
let's go to the credentials section
here if you go
in the
manage options you can see credentials
so go in the credentials
this is the credentials which i have
already created
go to the create credential options
click on it so enter the credential name
say i'll enter it as username
enter the description if you want any
and scroll down
and enter the attribute name
what attribute are you entering for
first we will enter the email address
so
select email address
and
select the input type as standard
description is optional
and enter the value what is the email
address so i'll enter my email address
scroll down and click on the plus here
to add
so there are two attributes in the login
page right that is the email address and
password so one attribute we have
entered the email address and the other
attribute is the password attribute so
select password
and input type as standard and since we
are entering the password it should be
masked
so that no one could see your password
the password should be encrypted so
enter your password here
after entering the password
so you have created the
you have filled all the credential
details click on create credential
so after clicking on create credential
your credential will be created
so that is how you create a credential
after creating the credential
so since i have already created a
credential i'll click on cancel before
creating
if you want to create the credential
enter all these details and click on the
create page
so i'll click on cancel so this is once
you create the credential you can see uh
like this a credential whatever you have
created it will be shown here
so this is how you create a credential
now after creating the credential you
need to
go to the locker section
and here you can see
create a locker click on create a locker
so enter the locker room whatever you
want
so let us enter username
after entering the locker room
go to the credential and select the
credential whatever you have created
since i have already entered the
credential in the locker that is why it
is
that is why this is disabled for me so
when you are entering the credential in
the locker room for the first time can
come inside the locker and select this
option check this option and click on
this so this will get
this will get deposited in the locker
this owners and managers section is
disabled the community edition so we
can't do any changes in that
this will also be disabled
this will also be disabled
go to the consumers
so enable this
enable this click on the
community edition user and
get deposit this in the locker click on
this
then scroll down so this is the last
then when you go back scroll up when you
finish doing all this this create locker
option will get enabled so when this
option get enabled click on create
locker and your locker will be created
that's how you create a blocker since i
have already created a locker i did not
so this options are not enabled for me
so this option is also not enabled when
you do all the steps this option gets
enabled
that is how you create a locker i hope
you have understood how to create a
credential and how to create a locker
so let's go back to the bot which we had
created let's go to the automation
so the bot which we had created was a
login bot
so we had selected the recorder
option in this recorder we had selected
the
action
password so we need to enter the
password
so
select here go to here
click on pick
and select the locker which we had
created the email address
select the credential that is the email
address credential
select the attribute attribute is the
password attribute we had entered two
attributes right one is the email
address and the password
so we are entering the password here
select the password attribute and click
on confirm
scroll down
here you can see we have picked the
password if you want you can enter the
time which is optional
you can see it is of the type user
password
so that's all save it
now we need a one more recorder action
that is to click on the
login button
so we'll select for the search for the
recorder
select the capture option
and we'll select the browser
select the web page
and click on the capture object
so the object which we are capturing now
is the login button so click on the
login button
here you can see recording capture
finalization
so the login button is being captured
so what action should be taken
so we need to click on the login button
here you can see if you have noticed
there is no option to set text why
because this is a login button when we
can't enter the text here so that option
is not here
so
from this options we should select the
click option
to login so we'll select the click
option
and you can see here
it is of the type login
button login
so we have selected the login button
now we'll save it
so we have completed the project in the
first step we have selected the browser
package in browser package we have
selected the open
action which opens the web page the link
page we have provided it opens the web
page in the second we have selected from
the recorder package we have selected
the capture option in which we have
captured the email address then we have
captured the password and then we have
captured to click on the login button
so let's save it we have saved it so
let's click on run and see
here you can see the webpage has opened
in the new window
email address has been entered
password has been entered
and it is clicking on the login page
and it is redirecting to the website
and here you can see the login but login
page has been open
so your what has run successfully
excel packages the excel package
consists of actions that allow us to
automate many of the tedious tasks while
working with microsoft excel
spreadsheets
the excel packages that automation
anywhere offers are excel advanced
package
to use the excel advance package command
we must first install the excel advanced
package it's utilized to automate
actions involving the workbook worksheet
rows columns and cells the system must
have microsoft office installed the
versions of microsoft office that are
supported range from microsoft office
2016 to 2090.
file formats like dot xls dot xlsx are
supported by this command
and it also supports the older excel
formats as well as the advanced excel
actions
and it requires the installation of the
microsoft excel application
next we have excel basic package
this package enables quick spreadsheet
activities for dot xlsx files without
requiring the ms excel software to be
installed
office 365 excel this package provides
commands for working with excel online
the office 365 xl bundle includes
actions that allow you to automate
operations in microsoft excel online
if you are using microsoft excel 365 via
a web browser you can use the office 365
xl package to automate excel process
let's look at the excel commands
some of the excel commands are
open spreadsheet this allows to open the
excel spreadsheet
close spreadsheet closes a spreadsheet
that was opened using the open
spreadsheet operation the excel command
identifies the spreadsheet using the
same session name as one used in the
open spreadsheet operation
save spreadsheet
this command saves a spreadsheet in an
open workbook
activate spreadsheet activates a
specific spreadsheet in an open workbook
it specifies whether to activate the
sheet by index or sheet by name
get cell
this command allows to retrieve the
values of a specific cell as well as the
range of the cell
set cell this command sets the value of
the active cell or a specific cell in an
excel spreadsheet you can assign a
variable to the cell value
go to cell moves to a specific cell
within a spreadsheet it can move one
cell to the left or to the right of the
active cell and it can move one cell
above or below the active cell or move
to the beginning or end of the column
delete cell
this command deletes the value in an
active cell or in a specific cell within
an excel spreadsheet
run excel macro runs a macro that is
stored within an excel spreadsheet enter
the macro name and specify the
parameters of the macro arguments let's
look at the demo in this demo we will
have two excel files
and we will use excel operations and
merge these two excel files
so let's jump into automation anywhere
so what we are doing is we have two
excel files i'll show you the files
so this is a excel file one
which has which has a data table of
employees and salaries
and we have another file
excel file 2
which has
the data table of employee names and
sales
so the file one has different names
employee names and different salaries
and the file to have different names and
different salaries so we will combine
both of this data table we'll create a
bot which will combine both of this data
table
so let's go to the control room
go to the automation section
and click on create new bot
name the bot
we'll name it as excel bot
click on create and edit
so after creating a bot
go to search actions and search for a
step
step action and double click on this
so what step action does is it runs a
sequence of commands
for example
to open a file 1 and file 2 there is a
sequence of steps and at the end of this
project there will be many list of steps
so which will be confusing so just to
avoid confusion we will drag and drop
this step and inside each step there
will be a number of actions
so we have
now that we have selected this action
step
give the title uh we'll name it as file
1.
so
go to excel package search for excel
so in excel advanced
since i have ms excel installed in my pc
so
i will use excel advanced
scroll down and select open
open action opens an excel spreadsheet
this action
works with xlsx and xls and all these
files which you can see here
so now after dragging and dropping open
option
you can select the file path from
control room desktop file or a variable
i have the file on my desktop so i'll
select desktop and i'll browse
so i'll select the file
that is file one and i'll open
so i have selected the file and our file
contains the headers so check this box
and check this specific sheet name so
that you can name the sheet
so our data table is in the sheet one
so type the name of the sheet and open
in read write mode or read only more so
we will open in read write more
and if you scroll down there is session
name so we'll keep it as default
so this much is done
next activity
so this action should be inside the
step
action so drag and drop it inside okay
next we need get multiple
cells double click on get multiple cells
get multiple cells retrieve the values
of multiple cells in an excel worksheet
so you can select range of cells to be
returned
all rows or specific rows or sell range
we we will select all rows since we want
to merge all the rows so select all rows
and select the read visible texturing
cell or read cell value
select any one of this and the session
name keep it as default
and you need to assign value to the
variable so we'll create a variable
since we are using the data table we'll
name it as table1
okay let's create and select
so we have selected the variable and now
we need to close the file so we'll
select the close action
so the close action closes an excel
spreadsheet
so double click
and
select the close option
here you can you should uncheck the save
changes when closing the file
and
name the session as default
okay so step one that is file one so
these three steps so this is done for
file one now we need to repeat this for
file two as well
so we'll save here till now
what we have done okay i will repeat
this for file two
let's drag and drop step
action
so in step two
name it as file two
we are performing this step for file too
okay
now
we'll go to excel package
and select open we need to open the file
so basically we are repeating this above
steps
and we will select the file too
so i'll go to desktop file browse and
select file to
so we have selected the file too and
this file also contains headers check
this box
and specify the sheet name as sheet1
we have the data table in 1 so sheet 1
and read and write mode
and
session name since the session name for
the file 1 is default and we need to
change here so we'll give it as default
2 as the session name okay
so this much is done now next we need
get multiple cells
so
double click on get multiple cells
we'll select all rows
and change the session name to default
two
and create a variable here so right
click and create a variable
name it as
table2
and
create and select
ok this is done
next we need to close the file
so
scroll up
and select the close action
and change the session name for file two
we have kept the session name as well
so we'll use the same system
file one and file 2 is created
so this actions are outside the file of
2
outside the step 5 too so we'll bring it
inside
these are supposed to be inside
okay now step one and step two is done
next we need to merge this file so go to
the data table package
so in this data table package you can
see all these actions we need the merge
action this merges two data table
together in a single data table
so
double click on merge data table
okay
so after double clicking on merge data
table enter the first table name so we
enter the data table name
we will select it as table one what we
had created in step one file one and
similarly we'll enter the second data
table name so these are basically the
two data tables which we want to merge
right then enter the name of the data
table in which we want to merge
so we want to merge it in either we can
merge it in the file one or file two but
we will create a new file and merge it
in the new file so we'll create a new
variable here
and we'll name it as table three
okay so create and select
so new data table is created to create a
new file to write it in a new file there
is an action here write to file this
writes a data table into a specified
file
so select this
and choose a variable that is table
three variable
and enter the file
so to enter the file name select the
file path where you want to create this
file so i'll select the file path of my
desktop
and from the desktop
i want to create a file as name result
file
result.csv
so i've created this file so to create
this file you need to check this box
create folders and file if it doesn't
exist
so this file doesn't exist i've just
named it here now well i check this box
so this file will get created
and check this overwrite existing file
so that when you run it for a second
time or third time the data doesn't
overlap so every time you run it a new
data has been overwritten so check this
box
and you can change this if you want row
delimiter to new line
or column delimiter comma and all this
okay so this is
done let's save
and let's run
it is downloading the dependencies it
will take a few seconds
or sometimes a few minutes
let's wait
so your bot has run successfully we will
go to the desktop and check the file
which we create here you can see the
result file is created
so we'll open this result file
so here you can see the result file
where both the tables have been merged
so from the row to tim
till the row 7 this was in the file one
and this last five rows were in the file
too so you can see here both the data
tables have been
now you can see her there that there are
rows repeated this row john is repeated
twice
so we don't want the rows to be repeated
we want to eliminate the rows which are
repeated
so for that
let's go here
so let's close this
and to remove the duplicate rows we have
an option here called remove duplicate
rows
remove duplicate rows removes the
duplicate rows from our data table
double click on remove duplicate rows
and take it above write file
okay so in remove duplicate rows
select the data table name
we want to remove duplicators from table
3 which is the merge data table
so select the table 3 variable and now
let's save it
and let's run
okay your bot has run successfully
now we'll go and check if the duplicate
rows have been removed
let's close this and go to the desktop
open the result file
and here you can see there are no
duplicators so there was an another
duplicate row here named john and that
row has been removed
and there are no duplicators left
that is how you remove the duplicate
rows
now let's see now we want this salaries
to be sorted we want this in order the
employee with the highest salary we need
him at the top and the employee with the
lowest salary we need him at the bottom
so let's go to the control room
to sort the data there is an action
called sort
this sort action sorts a data table on
the basis of column by ascending or
descending order
so double click on this
double click on sort and drag and drop
the sort action
bring it above right file
so in sort data table enter the data
table name will enter the table 3 which
is the merge data table and we can sort
by column name or column index we'll
sort it by name
and what is the column name which we are
sorting it is the salaries call right
so
let's type the column name
salaries
make sure the spelling is right
otherwise it will show an error
next we need to select the order in
which we want to sort we will select the
descending order because we want the
employee with the highest salary at the
top
so select the descending order
and let's save
and let's click on run
oops there was an error maybe the error
is because i have kept the excel sheet
open so i'll close the excel sheet
and run again
so here we go your bot has run
successfully
let's go and check if the data is sorted
let's click on the results
and here you can see
the data has been sorted in the
descending order the employee with the
highest salary is at the top and it's
decreasing in the order and the employee
with the lowest salary is at the bottom
so we have performed this operation of
sorting data
let's go back to the control room
let's close this there are similar other
actions in the data table there is a
assign or there is a sign action so
assign action assigns the value of the
source table variable to the destination
table variable
the change column type where you can
change the type of the column if it's an
integer you can change it to string and
if it's in string you want to change it
to integer then you can use this action
there is clear content there is clear
content action clears all the content of
specified data table and get the number
of rows you can get the number of rows
in this get the number of rows action
and you can delete any column if you
want you can delete row
insert column insert row
i have shown a few actions here you can
check out all of these actions and if
you have any doubt regarding any of
these actions you can comment in the
comment section and i'll try to answer
so you can delete column delete row
insert column or insert row similarly
you can join
join two data tables together as per the
column specified as per inner joint
outer joint full joint however you want
you can join the data tables
and the merge action we have must do two
data tables here
and you can remove the duplicate rows
get the number of rows search for value
but search for any particular value if
you want and search
and you can set the value of a single
cell and you can sort the data in
ascending or descending adder and write
to the file so you can write the data to
file
e so these are the actions present in
the data table
if you're planning to attend an
interview for an rpa or automation
anywhere developer role here is a
comprehensive list of most frequently
asked automation anywhere interview
questions with answers
we'll first look at the beginner level
questions
what is automation anywhere
automation anywhere is well-known
robotic process automation tool that
enables business to automate end-to-end
business operations
it provides powerful and user-friendly
rpa capabilities such as cloud native
web-based intelligent automation
solution for automating any complex
tasks
it is a web-based management system that
employs a control room to execute
automated tasks it improves the
efficiency of business process and
reduces the need for human labor
what are the features of automation
anywhere
automation anywhere offers an easy to
use interface for building bots and
designing business process automation
workflows
it supports multiple operating systems
such as windows linux and mac os
it consists of a recorder that works on
a variety of platforms including
microsoft windows citrix web and sap
it consists of different bot views for
collaboration flow view for business
users list view for developers and dual
view for collaboration
automation anywhere supports platforms
like javascript python and vbscript as
well as advanced variable capabilities
another key feature is its versatile
architecture that allows for the
addition of new command packages
what are the different components in
automation anywhere
automation anywhere robotic interface
aari
is a user-friendly interface that allows
business users to collaborate with bots
aari enables enterprises to unlock
previously unavailable automation
opportunities between humans and bots
that rpa could not address
iqbot an intelligent document processing
solution capable of reading and
processing a wide range of complex
documents and emails
iqbot intelligently captures classifies
and extracts semi-structured and
unstructured data using rpa and multiple
ai techniques allowing document-centric
business process to be automated
end-to-end
bot insight the analytics platform that
delivers real-time interactive and
intelligent insights into the business
process and operational intelligence
discovery bot an intelligent business
solution for enterprise business that
enables end users to discover automation
opportunities through process discovery
discovery bot collaborates with business
workers to identify automation
opportunities that can maximize the
return on your rpi investment
what is an enterprise control room and
how does it work
the enterprise control room serves as a
single point of management for all bots
the enterprise control room manages
schedules
executes and configures various bots and
bot runner capabilities using a
collection of specialized web services
the enterprise control room is placed on
a server in the data center and
configured to work with the other data
center components
explain the different type of bots in
automation anywhere
task
task boards are used for automating
repetitive tasks based on the rules
these tasks are simple to create and can
reliably complete multi-step procedures
document administration claims
management hr departments i.t and other
areas benefit from task bots
metabol metabots are more advanced
version of task bots metabots are
automation building components that help
with next generation integration
scalability
these are intended for a scalable
complex process
on a computer meta bots are used to
automate applications
iqbot iq bots are the next generation of
intelligent bots with the ability to
think like humans these bots are
designed to learn on their own and carry
out tasks in accordance with that
learning
iq bots also learn to recognize patterns
so that the bot knows exactly what to do
the next time the pattern appears with
each human confirmation it learns and
improves its ability to carry out the
act
explain briefly the architecture of
automation anywhere
automation anywhere platform is built
using a distributed architecture
the enterprise control room is a
web-based platform that manages the
development and execution of digital
workforce and provides a centralized
management
bot creators and bot runners are linked
to the enterprise control room bot
creators are software development
platforms for authorizing and
customizing automations
bot runners are runtime system deployed
on machines that carry out the
automations
bot runners can be installed on desktops
in data centers or in the cloud
what is a bot creator
a bot is a self-contained task that
requires little to no human intervention
to complete the bot creator is a
customized development client for
automation anywhere that is used to
create bots
task editor event watcher bot player
auto login and local scheduler are all
included
the bot creator also includes the
ability to create bots from a device
utilizing the enterprise client
application
the device is registered with the
enterprise control room after the bot
creator user signs in for the first time
and the user can deploy bots on that
device
is a bot runner
a bot runner has ability to run boards
from a device utilizing the enterprise
client application the device is
registered with the enterprise control
room after the bot runner user locks in
for the first time and the user can
deploy bots on that device
bots are run by bot runner which is a
software machine bot runners can run
bots at a scale after they have been
developed by the bot creator
explain triggers in automation anywhere
triggers integrate predefined events
into your process reducing the amount of
tasks that users must do repeatedly in
automation anywhere you can use
attendant automation to create unique
triggers for numerous apps these
triggers can then be used to launch a
bot
at triggers to have the bot execute
automatically whenever a specified event
occurs for instance pressing a specific
key or series of keystrokes
explain the benefits of automation
anywhere
time saving an easy to use interface
that allows users of varying skill
levels to easily use the product and
accelerate the learning process
with instant web-based deployment you
can get started with writing bots right
away
business adaptability
automation anywhere provides regular
updates ensuring that you are always up
to date on any device anywhere it
provides continuity of operations with
high availability and disaster recovery
low cost of ownership
there is no need for additional
infrastructure investment a unified
platform for front office back office
and employee applications
it gives lower maintenance cost
what are bought insights
the analytics platform that delivers
real-time interactive and intelligent
insights into business process and
operational intelligence
bot insight takes a large amount of
content level and productivity data
generated by deployed bots and converts
it into insights via automatically
generated and customizable dashboards
what are the different excel packages
that automation anywhere offers
automation anywhere offers three
different excel packages excel advanced
package it's utilized to automate
actions involving the workbook worksheet
rows columns and cells the system must
have microsoft office installed the
versions of microsoft office that are
supported range from 2016 to microsoft
office 2019
excel basic package enables quick
spreadsheet activities for dot xlsx
files without requiring the msxl
software to be installed
office 365 excel it provides commands
for working with excel online the office
365 excel bundle includes actions that
allow you to automate operations in
microsoft excel online if you are using
microsoft excel 365 via web browser you
can use the office 365 excel package to
automate excel process
let us look at the intermediate level
questions
explain functions of the following excel
commands
open spreadsheet
allows to open the excel spreadsheet
close spreadsheet closes a spreadsheet
that was opened
save spreadsheet saves a spreadsheet in
an open workbook
activate spreadsheet activates a
specific spreadsheet in an open workbook
it specifies whether to activate the
sheet by index or sheet by name
getcell allows to retrieve the values of
a specific cell as well as the range of
the cell
set cell sets the value of the active
cell or a specific cell in an excel
spreadsheet you can assign a variable to
the cell value
go to cell moves to a specific cell
within a spreadsheet
delete cell
deletes the value of a specific cell
within an excel spreadsheet
run excel macro runs a macro that is
stored within an excel spreadsheet enter
the macro name and specify the
parameters of the macro arguments
explain the types of triggers to start
abort
email
in email trigger a bot is launched when
a new email message arrives in the given
email service
such as microsoft outlook email server
or ews server
file and folder when a predefined file
or folder event occurs it starts a bot
as the trigger you can choose from the
following options like when you make a
new file or a folder or when a file or a
folder that already exists gets
destroyed or when you rename a file or a
folder
the next type is hotkey
when a predetermined combination of
keystrokes is performed on the keyboard
a bot is launched
as the trigger you can use any
combination like ctrl alt windows
and escape are all control keys
regular alphabetical characters are used
in the key
interface when the predetermined event
occurs on the selected user interface
element abort is launched
some instances of pre-configured events
are a button is pressed by the user or
an application is opened or closed by
the user a check box is selected or
cleared by the user
how to record the task with universal
recorder
step 1 create a new bot or open an
existing bot
then click on the start recording and
select universal recording step 3
perform the required steps and click on
finish
step 4 edit the actions and click on
save
let's jump into the automation in our
control room and see how to record the
task with universal recorder
so here we are in the control room we
have created a new bot
so let's search for a message box
double click on the message box
enter a message
close message box after five seconds
now go to start recording or you can
press ctrl plus r
click on start recording
and select the window which you want to
record
so
i'll select the calculator
and click on universal recorder
and now you can perform actions
so i am adding the numbers
so i have randomly performed some
actions now i'll click on finish and
let's finish the
recording
now let us save and click on run
so here you can see the message is
displayed hello it will close in five
seconds and it has closed
and the recording is being played
and it shows the actions which we have
recorded
you can see your bot has run
successfully
how to clone a bot in automation
anywhere
create a read-only duplicate of the bot
in the private workspace from the public
workspace so you can have a local copy
without checking it out
step 1. login into the control room as a
bot creator user
and then in public space click bots the
my bot page is displayed with the list
of folders or files containing the bot
then select the bot you want to clone
click the actions menu and click clone
task bot the clone bot appears in the
same folder structure in the private
workspace
so let's jump into the automation in our
control room and see how to clone a bot
so this is the my bot folder
so these are the bots which i have
created
so let's go to this python board select
this bot and go to the options
and
click here copy task bot
and here you can see a copy of that bot
is been created and name the bot
whatever you want so i'll keep the
default name python board copy one and
click on copy you can select the folder
where you want to store it i have kept
the default folders
and here you can see pythonbot copy1 has
been successfully created
so that is how you clone a bot
explain the following commands delay
command weight command and task command
the delay command is used to delay the
execution of next command for a set
length of time you have the option of
specifying the time in milliseconds or
seconds
wait command the wait command is used to
add a condition that forces the next set
of actions to wait for the contents of a
screen to change before proceeding
task command
task command is used to start a task
within a task or pause it and stop it
explain predefined variables in
automation anywhere
predefined variables are variables that
provide specific information about the
machine on which the bot is run
the values of a preset variable cannot
be changed by users
below are the examples of predefined
variables
activities you can manipulate data and
time variables
2
day 3 returns a date that includes the
hours minutes and seconds
day the day is written in state format
r
millisecond millisecond returns a value
between 0 and triple 9
milliseconds minute the minutes are
returned in minute format
month month is a function that returns
the month in month format
seconds the seconds are returned in
seconds forward
here
loops are one of the most powerful board
building constructions loops are the
instructions that repeat a set of
actions a certain number of times or
until a condition is met
i have the date you have a date
when a loop checks for the completion of
a defined number of iterations or
satisfaction of a condition
if not satisfied the loop is executed
the same conditions are checked
repeatedly until the condition has been
satisfied if the condition is satisfied
then the loop is not being executed
that comprises actions that make it
simple to handle exceptions that abort
encounters and pass control to the bot's
other activities that's all you have to
do you can use the error handler actions
to separate the actions that you can't
use to complete a task from the actions
or to handle an exception
when a bot meets an error handling
exceptions ensure that the work is
complete 23 23 23 23 20.
how is your submission anywhere
different from you i
[Applause]
on the basis of single integrated
automation platform automation anywhere
provides intelligent automation platform
like attended automation unemployed
automation intelligent document
processing and many more
whereas uipath requires third-party
products and integration to deliver a
similar solution
increasing installation and support
complexity
automation anywhere provides efficient
java based micro service architecture
ensuring scalability reducing the cost
of infrastructure and maintenance
uipath on the other hand built on a
legacy window workflow foundation with
the last update released in 2012 the
scalability is slow and difficult due to
lack of modularity
ease of use
in automation anywhere the easy-to-use
platform enables the regular employees
to create their own automation
but uipath is targeted towards the
developer community and needs more
intervention from it and development
teams
[Applause]
more secure and compliant
automation anywhere
provides the best in-class security
standard whereas uipath has incomplete
security certifications that create
business and
anywhere compliance scales to thousands
of bots in front and back office no
matter the type attended unattended or
document processing
ui paths architecture unable to scale
horizontally and required to duplication
of entire application for every service
expansion
quicker roi
in automation anywhere the modern
microservices architecture enables a
platform to scale both vertically and
horizontally delivering faster roi
in ui path with most deployments limited
to a single digit large scale
deployments become difficult
[Applause]
explain javascript package in automation
anyway the javascript package contains
actions that allow a bot to run
javascript
on windows linux and unix-based devices
these activities can launch javascript
the javascript includes the following
actions open
this action opens a javascript file in
automation element
close this action closes the session and
specifies the same session name from the
open action
run javascript action runs a function
within the javascript let's get to that
now let us look at some of the advanced
level automation
how to write inline scripts using python
command in automation anywhere
crazy step 1 create a new bot
and step 2 drag and drop the following
actions that is python script open
execute function and python script close
finally add a message box to display the
result variable yahoo
let us go to the automation
[Applause]
i'll open that board
[Music]
drag and drop the open function
in the open function specify the session
name if you already have an existing
file on your device
then select the import existing device
and enter the file path
or you can enter the input manually so i
have entered the input manually in which
i have defined a function
function which i have named it as name
and i have called an argument called
string
and i have returned that argument so
select the python runtime version in my
device python version 3 is installed so
i have selected degree
and then drag and drop the python script
in this enter the session name and enter
the name of function to be executed
as you can see here in the previous open
action i have entered the function name
as
name
so and enter this in the python script
action enter the name of the function
then argument to the function create a
variable so i have created a variable
and named it as python variable
so and i have assigned the value to this
variable
and i have assigned a value called
thanks to this variable
and then in the display message
enter the variable which you had created
so we had created
the variable python variable and
assigned it
so enter the variable
second
so select the variable and then close
the message box after 10 seconds then
once you open the python script then we
have to close the python script as well
and the session name should be the same
so for in detail explanation and better
understanding check out our tutorial on
automation anywhere using python check
out this video in which i have explained
all these steps in detail how python is
used in automation anyway
so now we'll click on save and
click on save
and run this
downloading dependencies
downloading dependencies
and here you go the message from the bot
is being displayed as thanks this was
the value which we had assigned to the
variable
and the window will close in 10 seconds
how to create a credential in automation
anywhere
step one navigate to bots and go to the
credentials section
then enter the credential name and
description for the configured
credential
then enter the attribute name and supply
the description for the attribute then
select the external keyword then select
input standard or user provided set the
security and click create credential
let's go to the automation anywhere and
create a credential
in the control room
go to manage
in the manage you can see credentials
click on credentials
and if you if you go here you can see
create credential click on create
credential
enter the credential name enter the
credential description which is optional
then scroll down
and enter the attribute name
whatever the attribute you want enter
the attribute name and enter the
description which is optional and
provide the input either you can keep
the input standard or user provided when
you keep the input as user provided when
the credential is added to the locker an
email will be sent to the consumer of
the locker so you will receive an email
but we don't want to receive an email so
we'll keep it as standard
and enter the
value so enter the value of the
attribute which you are creating and you
can keep the value it must when you keep
it masked the value gets encrypted
usually we use it for passwords when you
enter the password we encrypt the value
that is why we select mask and you can
create the attribute like this and if
you want you can create multiple
attributes click on plus and you can
create the multiple attributes once you
have created the attributes then when
you scroll up here you can see this
option create credential this option
will get enabled
then you click on create credential and
the credential gets created
this is how you create a credential
how to set up a locker and assign
credentials
step 1 create and assign roles step 2
create a credential and step 3 create a
locker
so it is very simple let's go to the
control room
go to the credential sections and this
you can see the lockers option here go
to lockers
and
click on create locker
once you click on create locker enter
the locker name enter the description
so in the credentials whatever
credentials you have created will be
shown here
so i have already deposited this
credential in the locker that is why it
is disabled for me
so once you have created the credential
check this box select the credential and
click here to deposit this credential in
the locker once that is done go to the
owners
and
select the owner
so your owner email address will be
shown here
select that email address and deposit
that in the locker once that is done go
to managers this is optional and this
manager is not enabled in the community
edition
and even the participants this is also
not enabled in the community edition so
skip these two steps and go to consumers
and in consumers check the community
edition user and deposit that in the
locker once this much is done you can
see this option create locker this
option will get enabled
so click on create locker and the
blocker will get created check out my
previous video on automation anywhere
excel operations in which i have shown
how to create a credential and how to
create a locker in detail
create a bot to login web page using
automation anywhere actions used in the
above question are as follows
we will use the browser package that
contains actions that enable you to
download files find broken lines and
launch a website
it contains a capture action from the
recorder package to capture an
interaction with the user interface
object such as text box button table etc
let's go to the automation in your
control room and create a bot to log in
web page using automation anywhere
so this is the login bot which i have
already created you can check out our
automation anywhere tutorial in which i
have detailedly explained each step
how to create a bot to login inside any
web page so basically in this we are
using a browser action
in the browser action we will open it in
a new window
will browse in the google chrome you can
select whichever you want
for now i have selected google chrome
and select the link to open
so in this project i will login inside
the simply learns webpage
so for that i have selected the link
that is the
link in this simply lens
so go to the simply lens webpage go to
the login page
and i have copied this link of the login
page
so i have pasted the link to open here
then i have used the recorder package
from the recorder package i have used
the capture action in which in the first
action i'll capture the email address in
the second capture action i'll capture
the password in the third capture action
i'll click on the login button
so i have captured this three action
so let us save and click on run
here you go it has opened the webpage in
the new
window
so entering the email address password
and clicking on the login button
and it has logged in inside the simply
learns web page
and your bot has run successfully
create a bot to merge two data tables
from a different excel sheets into a new
sheet
so to merge two data tables together in
a single data table in automation
anywhere we use merge action from the
data table package
so let's go to automation anywhere so i
have the two excel files file one and
file two so in file one i have
six rows
of employee names and salaries
in file 2 i have 5 rows of salary
of salaries and employee names so i'll
merge both these tables into a new excel
sheet
so for that
let us go to
let us go to the automation anywhere
control room you can check out our
automations anywhere excel operations
videos in which we have explained all
the excel operations and actions in
detail
in step one i have selected the file one
that is i have opened the excel file one
and assign it to get multiple cell
actions and close the file similarly in
step two i have opened the file too and
similarly assign the get multiple cells
and close the file tool then from the
data table package
from the data table package i have used
this merged action this merges two data
tables together in a single data table
so i have used this
so i have used this action so
i'll disable the
other actions click on save and run the
file
so the excel bot is running
and a new file name named as result will
be created on the desktop
so the bot has run successfully
let us go to the desktop and see the
result file which got created let us
open this file
and here you can see both the data
tables have been merged into a new excel
files
six first six rows from the file one and
the next five rows from the file tool
have been merged into a single data
table how to remove duplicate rows from
a data table in automation anywhere
to remove duplicate rows from the data
table use remove duplicate rows action
from the data table package
as you can see in this data table there
there is a duplicate row named john
which is repeated twice
so let us go to automation anywhere
and perform action to remove this
duplicate rows
so let us close this so if you go to the
data table action here you can see
remove duplicate rows
so double click on this and then you
will get the do double click on remove
duplicate rows and in do remove
duplicate rows select the data table
name so i'm selecting the data variable
which i had created so just specify the
data table name and the automation
anywhere will remove the duplicate rows
so
let us click on save and
let us run
here you can see the excel bot is
running
it is opening both the excel files it is
checking for duplicate rows and your
board has successfully run
so let us close this and go to desktop
and here you can see the duplicate row
has been deleted so there was one more
duplicate row with the name john
so that row has been deleted so this is
how you delete duplicate rows in
automation
from the excel from the data table the
last question
how to sort data in the data table using
automation anywhere
to sort data in a data table automation
anywhere provides a sort action from the
data table package
so if you look at this data table you
can see the salaries column the salaries
is not sorted so we'll sort the salary
scholar in the descending order
the employee with the highest salary
will be at the top and the employee with
the lowest salary will be at the bottom
so let's close this
and we'll enable this sort data action
so what you have to do is select sort
data
action from the data table package
once you select this specify the data
table name and the column name so we
want to sort the column salaries
then select the order in which you want
to sort we'll sort it in the descending
order click on save and click on run
here you can see deploying to the
computer downloading the dependencies
and the bot is running
so your bot has run successfully let's
go to desktop and open the file results
and here you can see the data is sorted
in the descending order the employee
with the highest salary is at the top
similarly in the decreasing order the
employee with the lowest salary is at
default ui path using python to invoke a
python script in ui path we must first
create a new sequence
then we should drag and drop the
following activities from the python
activities pack we need to drag and drop
python activity scope load python
activity invoke python activity and get
python object then we will use a message
box to display the result variable let's
jump into the uipath studio and explore
each of these activities in detail the
first thing we should do is go to the
manage packages
and
install python activities pack go to all
packages and search the keyword python
and here you will get
uipath.python.activities
so install this package click on install
and get it installed so i have already
installed it so i'll close this so let's
create a new sequence
we'll name the sequence as
python demo
let's create the new sequence now that
we have installed the python activities
package search for python keyword and
you will get the python activities
package so this pack allows you to call
python scripts and methods straight from
any workflow you may also provide input
parameters and obtain the output data
generated by the activities to the
invoked code so the activities present
in python activities pack r get python
object invoke python method load python
script python scope and run python
script so first we will drag and drop
python scope so python scope is a
container
that sets up a python environment and
provides a scope for python activities
all python objects loaded up to that
point are erased when the python scope
activity finishes
so we need to provide the path where the
python is installed so
the prerequisite is you need to have
python installed in your system the
latest version of python so search for
python where it is installed in your
system and go to the file location
since this is a shortcut go to the file
location and copy this file location and
paste the
location here in the path paste it in
the double quotes okay so now we have
pasted the location in the path and
target change it to 64 if it is 64 bit
and version you can change it to any
version which you have installed the
python version or you can keep it in the
auto so that's not a problem so after
dragging and dropping a python scope
drag and drop load python script get it
inside this do activity
so here you can write the code or if you
have an existing file you can copy the
file path here so i'll write a simple
code
so write it in the double quotes
so i'll define a function
say
i'll name the function as name
and i'll pass an argument
same message i'll pass argument as
message
and
return the argument
okay so i've written a simple code i
have defined a function and written that
argument so we'll create a variable here
right click create variable and name it
as say script
you can name it anything
name it as script okay the variable is
created so this load python script is
the command that converts python code to
a python object variable the generated
variable can be used to invoke the
methods in the code next we need
invoke python method
invoke python method allows you to run a
specified method directly in a workflow
from a python script the method
containing script must be first loaded
into the environment using the load
python script activity so we have first
loaded it with the load python script
activity then only we can use invoke
python method okay now we need to
provide the input parameters instance
and name instance is the variable which
we created previously in the load python
script we created a variable named
script so select that variable and name
is the function name which we had called
we had called the function name as
name
right in the previous load script
activity so we'll name the function here
so we have name the function as name and
we'll pass the input parameters so we'll
pass the input parameters here since we
are passing a string use double quotes
and i'll pass the parameter as
thanks for
watching
this video
so i have passed this input parameter
okay now in the result we need to create
an another variable so last time we had
created the variable called script so
we'll create this variable as script 1
okay next we need
get python object so drag and drop get
python object activity bring it inside
so get python object this method returns
the dot net type used in the python
script so go to the input python object
enter the variable which you had created
in the invoke python method we had
created a variable as script two right
script one so select that variable it is
the type argument is of type string
select the type stick since we are
passing a string and in the result
create an another variable right click
and create variable and we'll name the
variable as script two okay now we need
a message box to display the result but
before that we have used load python
script and invoke python method get
python object and python scope we have
used four of this activity and the one
activity left is run python script so
this command allows you to run python
code you can either type the code
straight into the activity or give it a
file path so we'll not use run python
script in this project so after this
much is done
we will search for a message box so drag
and drop a message box inside the python
scope so we'll enter the message here
the result variable which we had created
in
the previous activity get python object
is script 2. so to display the message
we'll enter that
variable script 2 so we need to convert
it to string so enter the function dot
2 string will concatenate it with the
text
say
subscribe to
our youtube channel so we have
concatenated a message
so we are all done so we'll save it and
click on run
and here you go you can see the message
thanks for watching this video and
subscribe to our youtube channel
automation anywhere is one of the
leading robotic process automation
platforms automation anywhere is built
on the world's most commonly used
automation and artificial intelligence
platform automation anywhere using
python in this we will write inline
scripts using the command python script
and its machine learning capabilities
within the automation anywhere
we'll first log in to the control room
and create a new bot then we will drag
and drop the following actions from the
python script package we will use python
script open execute function and python
script close
then we will add a message box to
display the result variable let's jump
into the automation anywhere control
room and explore the python script
package and each of its actions in
detail
login to the control room enter the
username and password click on login
once you have logged in the control room
go to the automation
click on create new bot
enter the bot name as python bot enter
the description which is optional
and select the folder where you want to
store the bot and next click on create
and edit
so the bot is successfully created
go to the search actions and search for
python script package
so the python script package contains
actions that enable python script
functions in a task
on the device where you wish to run the
script the relevant version of python
should be installed version 2.x and 3.x
of python are supported by automation
anywhere
the path of the python folder is
modified in the path environment
variable
enter the python on the command prompt
to see if python environment variable is
set correctly
the python environment is set up
appropriately if it returns the python
version that is installed
so these are the list of activities in
the python script package
close action closes the session and
specifies the name
execute function executes a function
within the python script execute script
executes a script within the python
script and open action opens a python
file so let's use open file now drag and
drop the python script open so enter the
new python session so enter the session
name by default the session name is
default so let's keep the session name
as it is and there are two options
one is to import the existing file if
you already have the file on your device
you can import it from the control room
file or desktop file or variable the
other way is to manually enter the code
so we'll enter a simple code
we'll define a function
let us name the function as name and
will pass an argument as message
will return the argument
message
don't forget to give colon in a function
so we have entered the simple two line
code select the python runtime version
if you have python version 2 installed
then select 2 if you have python version
3 installed in your device then select
3.
now next
drag and drop execute function
in the python execute function action
enter the python session
as it is default enter the name of the
function to be executed in the previous
action we have named the function as
name so enter the name of the function
and arguments to the function
so select the argument to the function
so we'll create a new variable
we'll create the variable as python
variable
and it is of the type
string so we'll select the type string
you can select whichever type you want
but for now since we are displaying a
message which is of the type string so i
will select the type string
and enter the value which you want to be
displayed
so i'll enter the value as thanks for
watching this video
subscribe to our youtube channel
so i have entered the default value a
message which is of the type string
if you want you can enter the
description which is optional and
click on create and select
so we have created a variable this
supports only zero or one argument you
can't pass more than one argument
and assign the output to variable so
which is obvious that we'll select the
variable which is python variable
and next subsequently we need a message
box to display the variable so i have a
search for a message
value a message drag and drop
type string enter the message box window
title when the message box is displayed
it contains a title so what title you
want the message box to be shown so
enter the title here so i'll keep as it
is the default title automation anywhere
enterprise client enter the message
so to enter the message
select the variable which we created
choose a variable python variable click
s insert
scroll bar after lines
so after how much distance you want the
message to be displayed in the message
box so select those many number of lines
next click on close message box after
check this box
and it's recommended to at least keep 9
or 10 seconds by default it is showing 5
seconds we'll change it to 10 seconds
so the message box is done now when we
have opened the python script we also
need to close the python script we'll go
to the list view
and
go to the python script package
and select close
action
and in the close action
make sure that the session name is same
the session name which you provided in
the python script open action and the
python name close and the python script
close action the session name should be
same let's save
python what is successfully edited and
saved
let's click on run
so here you can see the message thanks
for watching the video and subscribe to
our youtube channel so this window will
close within 10 seconds
so we had provided a 10 seconds closing
window so the window was closed within
10 seconds after the message was shown
then the
still the bot was running why because
after the message box we have provided
the python script close action that is
why the bot was still running and
closing the script so your bot has run
successfully in this video we will be
looking at the top 10 rpa projects
the first project is web scraping
it is also known as screen scraping web
harvesting web automation and web data
extraction because of its function
scraping is a method of extracting huge
amount of data from a website and saving
it to a local file or a database
businesses frequently search for
relevant information on a competitor's
or a specific website
however the data on the most websites
can only be read
there is no way to copy it for personal
use
as a result a time consuming action of
copying and pasting data is required
in a fraction of the time this can be
accomplished with robotic process
automation
the web scraping software is programmed
to load and extract the relevant data
automatically as a result you will save
energy and money
web scraping is used by a variety of
businesses from e-commerce stores to
stock dealers to obtain data
manual web scraping on the other hand
might be very costly
this is why business automate the
process
you can check out our video on uipath
web automation
where we have explained web automation
in detail along with the demo
the next project is crm upgrading
customer relationship management is a
set of techniques methods and
technologies for managing customer
interactions and data
crm is used to increase customer
interactions loyalty and sales across
the customer life cycle
employees in this field typically have
basic repetitive and rule-based work
with moderate or high volumes
making this a good choice for rpa where
a bot replaces human effort
rpa systems are designed to handle tasks
like this
rba can perform repetitive rule based
and high volume activities with ease
crm systems collect data about clients
from many channels and points of
interaction
the example of these channels are
company's website
phone
live chat
mail and social media
rpa systems are already in use and
completely functional
they can accomplish any repetitive task
that a human undertakes in a smarter way
using cognitive technologies
due to significant cost and operations
management benefits provided by rpa a
significant shift in business process is
projected to occur very soon
the next project is support sales and
marketing
sales and marketing departments are
among the most revenue generating areas
in many businesses
you want to free up your sales team to
do what they do the best that is sell in
order to create leads and drive growth
businesses large or small are
discovering that removing the hurdles
that prevent sales and marketing workers
from executing their critical can help
them maximize their time
rpa automates tasks on behalf of
employees by combining software robots
with business rules it is well known
that the interface of marketing and
sales is frequently used to attract new
customers
while marketing has advanced
significantly in terms of automation
sales productivity still relies heavily
on human involvement
nonetheless there are variety of sales
related sub functions that can be
automated a few of them are as
follows sales strategy and long-term
planning
forecasting
labor planning resource allocation and
channel strategy are all things that
need to be considered lead
identification and qualification
pipeline management as well as planning
for new and existing clients
pricing and quotations setting bits
coming up with technological solutions
negotiating and contracting are all the
things that are done in pricing and
quotation
management of orders credit checks
invoicing and order processing are all
things that need to be done
management of after sale services
monitoring follow-up and management of
post-sale request on a regular basis
assistive function
reporting analysis training
administration and the development of
sales materials
data generation or data migration
the process of moving data from one
location to another from one format to
another or from one application to
another is known as data migration this
is usually the outcome of introducing a
new data system or location
one-time activities like data migration
and test data generation are frequently
overlooked despite the fact that rps
ability to seamlessly connect systems
without the need for time and cost
intensive programming of interfaces and
standalone applications may be
particularly useful for these purposes
one of the most difficult aspects of
data transfer is the range of source
systems and as a result the variety of
data formats
to tackle this problem complex mapping
tables intermediate formats and data
cleansing are routinely used
this task not only increase migration
expenses but they also quickly escalate
to point where the complexity appears
unmanageable
rpa which automates typical process
provides a simple cost effective and
effective solution to all of these
issues
high adaptability at lower cost
rba is used to work with an almost
limitless number of systems interfaces
and data types
this feature is built in all rps
software systems and is available out of
the box
any client specific customizing can be
done quickly and easily
high quality data
because rpa uses existing guis rather
than bespoke interfaces any
discrepancies or data quality issues are
quickly detected by the underlying
systems
as a result before your migration data
is delivered to the destination systems
it can be scanned and corrected needless
to mention rpa can also be used to
generate any quality of test data needed
to improve the quality of the routines
documentation
rps software flexibility allows it to
create practically any lock file
required in a given situation
rpa may generate log files at any degree
of detail and in any file type like text
word excel pdf etc and then propagate
the results as needed
call center operation
when a customer contacts an agent the
agent must first identify them in the
system in order to obtain relevant data
such as order status order number order
location pending tickets and shipment id
this requires the agent interacting with
the customer while simultaneously moving
from one system to another the database
which contains the customer's
information and the other system which
contains additional information
customers must wait while the
representative is busy dealing with the
data sometimes asking for the
information that has already been
requested this tends to decrease
customer satisfaction and extends call
duration
rpa takes a user-friendly approach to
data integration and process management
the need to switch between direct
applications is eliminated by loading a
full customer profile from numerous
systems by automating actions such as
application launch mouse clicks field
entries and so on
when rpa is used in call centers it
drastically decreases the time it takes
to locate a customer in the system and
examine all information about them on a
single screen
as a result the customer does not have
to wait for the agent to load all the
information resulting in improved
customer service and shorter average
call length
onboarding of employees
hr is one of the departments that is
actively considering introducing rpa
into its working procedures with
particular focus on onboarding process
the onboarding process prepares new
employees for the new workplace by
providing them with essential knowledge
skills and behavior
this process usually begins before the
first day of work and is an important
aspect of integrating a newly hired
employee into the organization's payroll
and internal databases
employee onboarding sets the tone for a
new employee's career with your firm and
is crucial in preparing them to
contribute meaningfully
yet for the most part onboarding new
staff is still a tedious and wasteful
procedure
rpa improves hr procedures that are
still run on older system such as
onboarding by adding new functionality
decreasing human error and securing data
the organization was able to cut the
process time to 3-4 minutes per new
employee using a combination of rpa
robots
the greater accuracy of the automation
also reduced the time required for
examining and rectifying problems
previously
during high volume hiring periods the
system proved to be easily extendable
and the organization was able to
optimize data input resource allocation
and error handling by monitoring the
automated process
the task performed by rba bots in
onboarding process are winning resumes
fill-in process of new hire verify
candidates information
induction and training
employment management and send
notifications to the new employees
payroll processing
payroll processing is a critical company
operation that involves calculating
employees net pay after deducting
applicable taxes and deductions
payroll processing is one of the most
important but also one of the most time
consuming operations in any company
due to the importance of accuracy in
order to avoid stiff irs penalties
manually updating payroll system is
difficult and potentially costly because
of high level of risk and the time
consuming nature of manually updating
records businesses have begun to turn to
automation to reduce mistakes and time
wasted consider a scenario
where in every month an hr service
provider manually processed 100 000
payroll change occurrences
it took around 60 hours and 6 full time
personals to complete the process
the operation was inefficient and
complex because it comprised numerous
departments and two essential desktop
apps
all payroll updates received through
email from customers are now handled by
an
rpa robot which automatically inputs
them into a sap system
in approximately few weeks the rpa
solution was up and running automating
90 percent of previous labor necessary
to process this request
claims processing
claims processing is at the core of
insurance industry
the insurance company satisfies its
commitment to its consumers establishes
service standards builds credibility and
performs its commitments at this stage
many insurers have already implemented
some kind of automation
whether it's simple tasks like scanning
pdf documents or more extensive workflow
automation
these solutions on the other hand are
different and each have their own set of
issues
actually they can further add to the
complexity and difficulty of processing
the quality of the output from this
automation is mostly determined by the
programming quality
every time a step in the process is
altered the entire software must be
written
this complicates the claims process
exposes it to errors and adds to the
expenses this is where robotic process
automation enters the picture as fully
integrated end-to-end automation
solution that overcomes the existing
issues
rpa operates at presentation layer
seamlessly interacting with all
applications and systems including the
older system
it is completely scalable to meet the
needs of the user and offers robotic
accuracy of up to 100
legal processing
in terms of legal and compliance
processes this means that your lawyers
and specialists will be able to respond
more swiftly to the rising client and
internal stakeholder demands
in-house legal departments and
independent law firms both can benefit
from uipath robotic process automation
solutions for legal
this frees up all your highly qualified
legal professionals to focus on what
matters most learning the law and
providing best legal advice possible to
your clients
rpa automates operations on top of
existing systems such as legal documents
apps
spreadsheets
pdfs and websites
in simple editor you can quickly design
robots even lawyers and barristers have
the ability to develop their own
automation
the last project is data wiring for a
healthcare system
healthcare providers strive to provide
high quality care to as many people as
possible
however both providers and payers must
complete and handle a plenty of forms
documentation and data in order to do so
all of this data like patient records
provider information billing and payment
information is collected processed filed
and stored in the mess of segregated and
separate systems
healthcare has become confusing and
sluggish due to a plethora of process
and networks resulting in care that is
potentially more expensive slower and
ineffective for patients
this also means lower profitability for
private suppliers
robotic process automation is a tool
that aids in the digital transformation
process
in a nutshell it's the wiring that
connects all of the data in all of the
systems in a way that's faster more
accurate and more efficient than
traditional id approaches like complex
business process management system
custom application program interfaces
and other
rpa when combined with artificial
intelligence can swiftly and accurately
push and draw a large amount of data
from one system to another
in addition to speeding up the system it
frees up humans to undertake more
value-added work by removing
time-consuming low-value jobs from their
hands
now if you're looking to make a career
in this field and if you're just
browsing around for jobs then you're in
the right place this video will
absolutely help you crack that next
interview of yours
the first question is what is rpa
now robotic process automation is the
use of software with artificial
intelligence and machine learning
capabilities to handle high volume
repetitive tasks that previously
required humans to perform now some of
these tasks could be addressing queries
making calculations maintenance of
records or even performing transactions
now rpa is a form of automation that
basically sticks to the front end of the
system and carries out tasks without
having to move to the back end now this
is an essential feature of rpa
next up is mention a few applications of
rpa
there are several applications to
mention a few we have open mails and
attachments fill in forms and move files
and folders
follow if then rules connect to system
apis extract structured data from
documents make complex calculations
monitor manual processes and learn how
to perform them
read and write databases scrape data
from documents and even log into web
enterprise applications
next question is mention a few
advantages of rpa
firstly rpa reduces cost now by
automating tasks the cost saving of
almost 30 can be achieved through rpa
rpa reduces operational risks various
companies prefer to outsource busy work
to external parties now this comes with
an inherent risk of human errors and
inefficiency now rpa brings forth a
better solution and since work stays
in-house there's less operational risk
next up is quality and accuracy rpa
offers services to processes with a high
probability of human errors thereby
increasing accuracy robots are reliable
and consistent and don't complain when
expected to work tirelessly
next up is scalability with the help of
rpa companies can make adjustments based
on seasonality and can easily scale up
or down the operation as needed
reduced workload
automating tasks like report making can
significantly reduce the workload on the
employee allowing them to focus on other
critical tasks
improved customer satisfaction since
accuracy is maintained and operational
risk is minimal customers are provided
with quality content
lastly we have improved business results
since all employees are focusing on
activities that add more value to the
company improved results in the business
are visible
the next question is what are some
industries that can benefit from rpa
there are several industries and domains
that are currently benefiting from rpa
to mention a few there's banking and
finance iit integration processes human
resources insurance agencies marketing
and sales and customer relationship
management
moving on to next question what are rpa
tools
now to meet the objectives of rpa rpa
tools are used
they are the software with the help of
which one can configure tasks and build
bots to automate them
some of the popular ones in the market
today are uipath blue prism automation
anywhere work fusion and redwood
moving on to next question explain the
working of rpa
now the typical working of rpa includes
four crucial stages
the first stage is planning in this
stage the processes to be automated are
defined which includes identifying the
test objects finalizing the
implementation approach and defining a
clear roadmap for the rpa implementation
the next step is design and development
in this phase you start developing the
automation workflows as per the agreed
plan
thirdly we have deployment and testing
this phase typically includes the
execution of the bots any unexpected
outages are to be taken care of during
the deployment to ensure accurate
functioning testing of these pots for
bugs and errors is crucial
lastly we have support and maintenance
providing constant support helps in
identifying and rectifying the errors
better
moving on to the next question what is
the difference between traditional
automation and rpa
here's a simple image for you
now to go on to talk about the
differences
traditional automation involves
programming apis and integration tools
to integrate different systems
rp on the other hand mimics the actions
of a user at the user interface level in
the case of traditional automation the
developer needs to have a good
understanding of the target system while
in rpa as long as the bot can exactly
follow the steps the developer need not
worry about the underlying complexities
the next question is mention the types
of rpa
now basically there are three types of
rpa
first up is unattended or autonomous rpa
now this is ideal for reducing work like
completing data processing tasks in the
background they do not require any human
intervention
now these bots can be launched at
specific intervals or they could be
bought initiated or they could be
triggered by some data input
next up is attended rpa now these bots
live on the user's machine and are
triggered by the user
they can be launched when embedded on an
employee's device or they can be
autonomous based on certain conditions
or they can be launched using the rpa
client tool
lastly we have hybrid rpa it is a
combination of attended and autonomous
bots now these bots address front and
back office tasks in the enterprise
the next question is what are front and
back office spots
now front office bots are those whose
deployment is totally in the user's
control they require human intervention
they work from the same desktop as that
of the user it can only be triggered by
local machines manually and cannot run
remotely
when it comes to back office boards
these bots can run on locked machines
from the orchestrator
the user may not be actively involved in
its working and these bots can be
triggered remotely by servers
the next question is what are some
features of rpa
first up is rich analytical suite now
rpa monitors and manages automated
functions from a central console
now this console can be accessed from
anywhere and offer basic metrics on
robots servers workflows and more
simple creation of pods
rpa tools allow quick creation of bots
effortlessly by capturing mouse clicks
and keystrokes with built-in screen
recorder components
scriptless automation
rpa tools are code free and can automate
any application in any department
employees with less programming skills
can create bots through guis
security
rpa tools enable the configuration as
well as customization of encryption
capabilities for securing certain data
types to defend against the interruption
of network communication
hosting and deployment rpa systems can
automatically deploy bots in groups of
hundreds hence rpa can be installed on
desktops and deployed on servers to
access data for repetitive tasks
debugging some rpa tools require to stop
running to rectify the errors while
other tools allow dynamic interaction
while debugging this is one of the most
powerful features of rpa
moving on
what are the major differences between
blue prism and uipath
moving on to the first feature is trial
version
blue prism offers a trial version it's
available in two options either on cloud
or on the local computer ui path on the
other hand offers free edition both
trial and license versions are available
moving on to base technologies blue
prism is completely based on c-sharp
uipath is based on sharepoint kibana and
elasticsearch
moving on to process designer blue prism
allows you to create design edit as well
as test business processes from the
visual business object
but what exactly is a vbo
a vbo can take the form of a set of
coded functions which may be written in
bb.net or csharp.net
uipath acts as a visual process designer
with friendly developer options now a
visual process designer basically is a
dashboard consisting of various tools
through which a developer can define the
automation tasks
moving on to accessibility blueprism
allows only browser-based accessibility
ui path on the other hand provides
mobile and browser accessibility
moving on to robots blue prism offers
back office automation only while uipath
offers both front and back office
automation
the next crucial factor is a macro
recorder
in case of blue prism a macro recorder
does not exist
while in the case of uipath it consists
of a macro recorder enabling faster
process mapping
moving on what is citrix automation
any automation solution
built using a virtual desktop or built
to work in virtual desktops is citrix
automation it plays a major role in
small to corporate companies like bpo
and contact centers where applications
are being accessed remotely because of
security considerations
next question is what is uipath studio
now uipath studio is basically a
platform to create the automation bots
it encompasses hundreds of activity
templates and ready-made components to
drag and drop
ui path studio consists of first up is
gui dashboard it offers a visual
dashboard with activities like send
email display message and so on
it also consists of different types of
recorders uipath studio offers various
recorders to record actions on multiple
platforms
next up is logging and exception
handling it offers various options for
these two such as debug open logs slow
step etc
lastly it offers reusable components
here the user can create usable
components to publish them together as
libraries
moving on what are activities in uipath
the activities panel shows available
activities that can be added to the
current workflow users can use the
search box to find various activities
navigate through them using navigation
keys and press
system activities pack contains all the
basic activities used for creating
automation projects these activities
enable the robots to manipulate data
tables by adding or extracting
information or directly interact with
directories and files on your machine
performing any action a human user would
also there are other types of activities
in the pack that aid in the creation and
execution of automation projects
themselves such as logical operators and
expressions
moving on what is a sequence in ui path
a sequence is a simple linear
representation that flows from top to
bottom and defines which activities are
to be performed
all right you can see a simple example
on your screen here
so to give you a detailed explanation
let me just navigate to uipath
and here i can create a new sequence i
go to new click on sequence
and let me call it sequence as it is and
say create
all right now a sequence is created so i
want to display two messages so let's
look for the activity that is message
box
i drag and drop it here
and let me display hello first
and i drag another message box and after
that i drop it here
and
okay let me do that again
all right and here i display welcome
all right
so let's save this
and debug
according to the logic hello has to be
displayed first and then welcome right
so let's go ahead and see if it does
that
all right you see a hello message first
followed by which you can see the
welcome message
so this is what a sequence is
moving on to the next question what is
scraping in uipath
now scraping can be done in two ways
first up is data scraping now this is a
technique with the help of which
structured data can be extracted from
the web or any application and saved to
a database or a spreadsheet or a dot csv
file
in the case of screen scraping it is a
process of collecting screen display
data from one application and
translating it so that another
application can display it
now you can see the two options on the
top of your user interface in uipath
moving on
what are uipath robots
now uipath's robots run the automation
that is created using the uipath studio
now there are two types of robots as
discussed earlier we have attended
robots now they work with you to speed
up the process like service desk
operation or help desk operations now it
is used in activities where human
involvement is key
next up is unattended robots now these
operate without the human touch
maximizing cost and performance benefits
for any variety of back office tasks
next question what does the uipath
orchestrator do
now the orchestrator is a centralized
robot management dashboard where you can
easily deploy secure and manage your ui
path robots at scale
first you have to create the bot
the project is then published as a
process for further use once a process
is created it is assigned to a specific
robot to execute in an environment
this collectively constitutes a job
all of this is taken care of by the
uipath orchestrator
next question how is exceptional
handling achieved in uipath
exception handling is one of the error
handling methods in uipath the error
handling activity has four options
first up is rethrow now using this
activity a robot throws an exception
again which was previously caught while
executing the workflow for this activity
we don't need to provide any specified
message
secondly we have terminate workflow now
this is a mechanism where we can ask the
robot to terminate rest activities
this activity is mostly used when there
is no data to process
to use this activity we may need to
provide the exception message which the
bot may login the error rock file which
we can refer to later
third is throw through activity is a
mechanism wherein if a bot fails to
execute a mentioned activity it throws
an error with a specified error message
to help us understand better
lastly we have try catch now this
activity has three parts the try block
would be executed and if there was an
error it will be caught in the catch
section
now after executing the try block robot
will execute the finally block in any
condition
moving on what are break points in
uipath
breakpoints are used to purposely pause
the debugging process on any activity
that may trigger execution issues
you can place and modify a breakpoint on
any of the activities as follows
so from the context menu you can right
click on an activity and select toggle
breakpoint so let me show you how that
works
so here
in my sequence i can just right click on
it
and here i you can see the toggle
breakpoint option you can go ahead and
click on that that is one of the methods
or i can select the activity and click
on
the breakpoints button on the debug tab
so let me show you
here let me select this
and in my debug tab
i can click on breakpoints and say
toggle breakpoint
that is another method and lastly i can
press f9 while the desired activity is
being selected
it's as simple as that
moving on to the next question what is a
macro recorder
a macro recorder allows you to record
mouse events and keyboard activities to
generate automation scripts
now the activities are arranged based on
the sequence of actions being performed
on the screen right so this sequence is
saved in your workflow which you can
later use it to play back the recorded
moving on what are the user events in
uipath mention a few
now user events and ui path specify the
actions performed due to the occurrence
of certain events
right some of these events could be
click key press or monitor mouse or any
monitor keyboard etc
so when it comes to on click element now
this basically monitors all the click
events on a specified ui element the
mouse buttons left right and middle are
used for the click action
by default the left mouse button is
selected
on prepress element now this monitors
keyboard events on a specified ui
element
special keys are supported and you can
select them from the activity drop down
list this field supports only strings
and string variables
on click image this monitors the image
defined by the target ui element for
mouse input
at monitor mouse this monitors a
specified mouse key combination system
system-wide event
moving on
we have what are the different
activities performed by uipath
we have core activities for automation
processes
cognitive activities for language
translations credential activities for
enabling the addition or deletion of
credentials database activities
basically used for executed queries
transactions etc we have excel
activities for automating ms excel tasks
ftp activities for performing functions
on the ftp server
intelligent ocr activities for
digitization and scraping we have mail
activities for working with imap pop3
smtp outlook
we have pdf activities for data
extraction from pdf
python activities for invoking python
scripts and methods
terminal activities for retrieving data
from the terminal we have web activities
for performing soap and http requests to
any web apis and their word activities
for automating activities in ms word
so these are the few you could mention
moving on what does the control room in
automation anywhere do
the control room is a web-based platform
that controls automation anywhere all
right the control room deals with user
management source control
i mean the code for the bots is managed
by the control room
dashboard it gives complete analytics
and results of automation anywhere bots
and license management the purchased
licenses for automation anywhere
configured in the control room now there
are two types of licenses in automation
anywhere you have the device license
which allows you to create a board edit
bot and then run a bot and you have the
run license when the user can only run
the bot and cannot make any changes
so this is what the control room does
moving on to the next question what is a
bot runner
now a bot runner is the machine where
you run the bot now you could have
multiple bots running in parallel you
only need the run license to run the
bots
the boss will report back the execution
logs pass fail status back to the
control room
moving on what are task bots meta bots
and iq boards
so task bots basically are the bots that
automate a rule-based repetitive task in
areas like documentation administration
hr claims management etc
moving on to metabots these bots are the
automation building blocks it is
designed in such a way that with
application changes or updates you need
to make minimal edits to this board any
changes made to the bot is easily
reflected
lastly we have the iqbots now this is an
advanced tool it can learn on its own
and perform a task according to it
iqbots offer automation using highly
advanced cognitive technology
moving on is robotic process automation
similar to screenscaping or macros
now screen scraping mostly talks about
the old green screen applications
mainframe ones where you basically
capture the screen
you process it based on its content and
information that you have
when it comes to rpa it is more
intelligent
more capable and much more robust
what it does it connects to the elements
whether they have windows applications
or java applications does not matter
they connect all the elements it does
use screen scraping yes but it's just a
part of robotic process automation
they're not entirely the same
moving on what are thick and thin
clients
a thick client is the application that
requires certain attribute features
using rpa tools example a computer a
calculator or internet explorer while a
thin client is the application that
never requires the specific properties
while using the rpe tools
very simple
the next question is how is a chatbot
different from rpa
now a chatbot is basically a bot that is
programmed to chat with the user like a
human being would right while in case of
rta it is a bot that is programmed to
automate a manual business process of
executing a task or any activity with a
business function
all right so a chatbot can be used as a
medium to feed input to the rpa board
but it cannot replicate the features of
an rpa system
moving on to the final question can
selenium be used for rpa
well there are lots of test automation
tools in the market today like selenium
qtp and apm these are good test
automation tools and no they cannot be
used for robotic process automation test
automation tools have a constraint they
require software in order to run
but in case of rpa it can be applied to
anything other than a product
and mostly rpa is used to automate
business processes
so selenium or any test automation tool
for that matter cannot be used for rpa
so with that we have come to the end of
this rpa developer full course
if you enjoyed watching it make sure you
hit the subscribe button and press the
bell icon to never miss an update
thank you so much for being here watch
out for more videos from us until then
keep learning and stay tuned to simply
learn